Und das too.
Pock!
ich hab gerade unten huge pepo fett gemacht ich hab 3 würstchen gefuddert ja warum nicht
ich war in letzter zeit so wenig on weil mich tausend sachen abgelenkt haben muss jetzt
wieder ein bisschen regelmäßiger streamen ich hab ja teilweise ich glaub ich hab die letzten
drei wochen nur am sonntag gestreamt 2 und halb 3 oder dreieinhalb stunden sonst nix ganze
woche nicht und außerdem bald ist es soweit bald wirds kühler wenn man sich jetzt mal hier
anschaut jetzt will einer auf dem handy was geil aber ich zeune heute bestimmt nicht dem täglichen
austausch daily ganz bestimmt nicht heute ich arbeite montags nicht jetzt habe ich ganz vergessen
was ich sagen wollte vollkommen mischbrot dankeschön 19 monate hyper subscription habt ihr
schon das neue stack overflow survey 2000 spricht man überhaupt so aus survey survey spricht man
das aus pronunciation wie spricht man das aus survey survey survey na war doch gar nicht so
verkehrt weiß ich aber das schon gesehen habt gab jetzt ja hier eine neue umfrage vom april
oder so am mai mai hier vom mai und die haben sie jetzt ausgewert es ist tatsächlich recht
interesting aber falle 22 monate ja scheinen zu funktionieren dankeschön für den zapp
massive subscriptions ja und außerdem wetter online ha no außerdem wirds bald kühler und
ich muss endlich einstellen dass ich meine heizung an und ausschalten kann das müssen
wir jetzt fertig machen scam train ist am start ja ja nachdem ich die letzten drei ich muss
leute ich muss ein bisschen beruhigen ganz ganz wir machen wieder sehr äußerst dass
ich auch eine weile online bleiben kann muss bisschen bisschen beruhigen und und dann auch
gleich nachdenken was wir machen ja und demnächst wirds kühl sieht man ja hier schon minus minimal
temperatur 8 bis 6 grad nächste paar tage ich muss heute nicht arbeiten ich habe montags
immer frei ich habe halt ich habe die letzten wochen einfach nur so wenig gestreamt bald
schnee genau ganz stells und deswegen bald muss ich die heizung einschalten wenn man
sich das hier so anguckt tagsüber 17 18 13 grad da muss ich die heizung einschalten und
die heizung würde ich natürlich am liebsten von meinem home assistant dashboard einschalten
und deswegen muss ich den kram jetzt endlich fertig programmieren weiß gar nicht wo man
genau steht oh oh broken af oder auch nicht ja was denn jetzt nein nein nein lull feedback
keck wait ja und ich will ich will die heizung einschalten können und wir haben ja hier
schon so einen testserver installiert das mal kurz ip gucken was für eine ip hat das
ding 2 1 3 3 ja ich habe mir hier schon so den test so einen home assistant testserver
gemacht der halt nichts nichts nichts hat ja vielleicht müssten wir den auch mal updaten
was ich da ist ja schon ein bissl bissl und zwei drei wochen am laufen waren das jetzt
noch mal system echt ist das die neueste ja gut 3.9 muss ja die neueste sein ja oh
na gut egal ja und ich will halt einen button haben wo ich hier sagen kann heizung anheizung
aus und bloß noch ein paar infos von meiner von meiner heizung und ich will die hier in
der integration drin stehen haben komplett als eigenes gerät dass es alles schön gruppiert
ist das heißt ich muss mir jetzt erstmal angucken wie das überhaupt richtig funktioniert
mit der home assistant mqtt discovery das haben wir nämlich das letzte mal nicht gemacht
das letzte mal haben wir glaube nur abfragen gemacht von der heizung selbst ja wir haben
das letzte mal nicht viel gemacht also wenn das letzte mal 61 zeilen hingekriegt haben
und wir wissen ja bezahlung nach zeilen ist ja eh das beste haben wir nicht viel verdient
dings bums bamm dings 15 monat huge subscription der neuro mom ist auch am start fünf monate
hier huge subs ja weiß ich ob ihr das wie gesagt weiß ich ob ihr das hier gesehen habt
scheint ja wohl relativ neu zu sein hier dark reader an da muss man kurz weg machen
ich da ich jetzt müsste erzählen dass es schon monat alt ist ne siehst du das kam
kam letzten monat raus ich glaube das haben wir uns noch nicht zusammen angeguckt was
ich diesmal was ich diesmal wieder ganz interessant finde eine güde oder haben uns das schon
angeguckt doch ich glaube das haben wir uns sogar schon angeguckt wird das auf github
veröffentlicht ich fürchte dass brätinix bringen wenn man das auf github veröffentlichen
weil du wahrscheinlich eine ganz andere heizung hast was ist denn für eine heizung also ich
habe eine ich habe von wiesmann eine 222 w oder so sowas hier glaube ich glaube das
ist meine heizung oder 222 f oder sowas ja also man braucht ja da mehrere komponenten
du brauchst auf jeden fall ein raspberry pi am an der heizung mit dem offiziellen ob
du also muss es kein offizielles muss kein offizielles kabel sein aber du brauchst
ein raspberry pi und ein opto link kabel und wie kontrol von von github
ja dann kannst du das wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich verwenden ich muss mal gucken das steuern
habe ich hinbekommen das ist das ist prognosen also das ein und ausschalten da muss da musste
man das letzte mal musste man da musste man selbst rausfinden wie das funktioniert ja
wie gesagt das habe ich als heizung und es auch ein bisschen davon abhängig wie dann
wie kontrol eingestellt ist
first line of code es gibt ein prozent der leute die haben ihre erste zeile programmiert
als sie jünger als fünf jahre waren
ob ich das mal glauben soll
das ist ja beim programmieren nicht so wie bei den ganzen klavier geige sonst was genies
die dann irgendwie mit eineinhalb jahren das erste mal klavier gespielt haben
du musst ja wenn du das programmierst so halbwegs im kopf verarbeiten können was
da was da logisch passiert
guck mal es gibt sogar leute die haben erst mit 64 jahren und älter angefangen
aber die meisten leute gut ja in dem alter habe ich auch angefangen
ockers stellz
wisst ihr dass ich eigentlich ursprünglich komplett gehasst habe zu programmieren wir
haben in der schule hatten wir bei irgend so einem komischen lehrer ich weiß nicht mehr
wie der hieß aber den mochte ich nicht
der hat uns versucht ein bisschen zäh beizubringen und ich habe das gefühl also jetzt so im nachhinein
glaube ich hatte selbst keine ahnung gehabt was er da eigentlich fabriziert hat
und ich habe das komplett gehasst aber der hat das auch nie richtig erklärt
außerdem ist c naja weiß nicht so als einstieg vielleicht nicht das beste
ist ja nicht so als hätte damals sich auch schon irgendwas alternatives gegeben
und sei es zum beispiel basic oder irgendwas wo man die leute vielleicht nicht ganz so
abschreckt
c ist immer noch besser als java naja zum einsteigen zum einstieg weiß ich nicht
denn meiner vorteil an c ist halt dass es äußerst minimalistisch ist
und c kann halt nichts außer das was es kann und es kann es halt gut
also du hast ja bei c würde ich ja nicht mal von einer standard library sprechen
dann würde ich vielleicht von absolut notwendigen essentials so quasi sprechen was da dabei
ist
und ja ich glaube nicht dass c so eine wirklich gute einstiegsprogrammiersprache ist
also dann hätten sie lieber mit uns in der schule damals es muss ich meine es muss ja
nicht wischlbasics sein es hätte auch paskal oder irgendwas sein können
irgendwas irgendwas anderes als c und vor allem unser lehrer hat uns dann auch irgendwas
von pointer erzählt und so was ich hab es halt damals überhaupt nicht gecheckt
wisst ihr wie lang ich wie lang ich gebraucht habe um wirklich dabei ist es eigentlich
eines der elementarsten sachen schlechthin wie lang ich gebraucht habe um mir unter einem
pointer was vorstellen zu können dabei ist es eigentlich total einfach
ein pointer ist die kombination aus einer speicher adresse und einem typ
fertig ein pointer sagt dir als als was du das was an dieser speicher adresse stehst
interpretieren kannst gut bei c kannst du sagen das ist ein void pointer dann hast du
prinzipiell gelitten wenn du es nicht eh schon weißt weil kriegst du sonst nicht raus
was es ist
das ist das ist eigentlich eigentlich das eines der elementarsten elementarsten sachen
und ich glaube das lag mit an diesem lehrer dass ich da so kein bock drauf hatte die meisten
können es nicht erklären weil sie selbst nicht verstanden haben ja das stimmt übrigens
heute hat mich auf twitter einer voll verwirrt er hat mir gepostet
hier haben wir das hier gepostet gestern auch drüber gesprochen und da habe ich mir gedacht
was ist ich meine ich bin dann drauf gekommen dass es wahrscheinlich swift ist aber da habe
ich was zum teufel ist das für eine sprache ich dachte erst mal als ich gesehen habe gesagt
javascript aber dann ist mir auf keinen moment das da und das da das passt ja überhaupt
nicht zu javascript dann dachte ich dass es irgendwie sowas vielleicht wie go ist wegen
fang ist es aber auch nicht kann es auch nicht sein und irgendwann bin ich dann drauf gekommen
dass das wahrscheinlich swift sein müsste hat recht es ist swift
ah siehst du siehst du und $0 ist so pearl magic variable
was ist das für einen font es ist bestimmt so ein font der auch so so geile extra zeichen
für größer gleich und gleich gleich und so hat ich hab wie hieß wie hieß der kram noch
mal und li li li li li shape li li li li li li li li li li li li li li li li li li li li li li li li li li li
legatoren wahrscheinlich auf deutsch keine ahnung wo du dann solche dinger machst wann
kommt der dritte quer que esa service stream ja wie gesagt ich war die letzten wochen abgelenkt
mit allen möglichen sachen plus dazu dass ich ein richtig cooles rpg gerade rausgekommen
was ich nebenbei abends immer noch noch spiele also ich habe die letzte wochen
bisschen wenig gestreamt ich war zu sehr abgelenkt durch alles mögliche
wir machen aber dann ich würde sagen nächstes wochenende
nächstes wochenende wir müssen kekwsservice endlich mal hier to the moon
ja an start bringen wer sich fragt was kekwsservice ist das ist ein stream
projekt gibt sogar auf github kekwsservice
das ist nicht das ist aber auch von jemand aus im stream kekwsservice das ist nicht
mein kekwsservice wo ist es denn ist es doch ja das ist so ein kleines mini
projekt warum sind da so viele einser drinnen
zumindest einser na gut dass ich einser kopieren kann ja das ist das ist ein
projekt wie man eine minimal asp.net anwendung dann nach und nach in die
cloud bringt das haben wir mit den letzten paar streams schon gemacht es
macht nichts anderes wie kekw als bild zu nehmen und dann immer weiter zu
rotieren was habe ich diese einser in die readme reingemacht so schonmal nicht habe ich hier die einser in die readme gemacht auch nicht wann habe ich denn diese ganzen einser in die readme gemacht
man weiß es nicht na gut gucken wir mal wann habe ich wann habe ich denn die readme angepasst history fix randomness aha als ich die randomness gefixt habe alles klar
sehr sehr schlau so sieht das also aus wenn man randomness fixt alles klar max ach
stimmt das war dass ich ach das war dass ich meine github actions testen konnte wo ich die
readme immer geändert habe stimmt ganz ganz ja das wäre das vielleicht auch was was ich
hätte reverten sollen naja
ansible ist ja also wirklich poc richtig massive poggers hast du ein tipp für
zeugs dass ich lernen kann nachdem ich jetzt die basics von htl von html css etwas jquery
jquery braucht man eigentlich nicht mehr jquery ist eigentlich es ist zwar immer noch das weit
verbreitete web framework aber nur weil es in so vielen sachen noch mit drinne ist also
jquery braucht man eigentlich ja dann ja also wenn du wirklich noch wer web zeug machen willst würde
ich dir empfehlen dass du irgendeinen halbwegs verbreitetes webfront entlernt lernst da gibt
es eigentlich drei stück aber vielleicht vielleicht vier vielleicht vier wenn man
zwelt noch mit nimmt aber genau du hast die du hast die drei du hast angular react und view also
wenn ich dir was zum einstieg empfehlen würde aus diesen drei dann ist es eindeutig view weil
ich das von der struktur her und den tutorials und dem kann ich finde ich persönlich am schönsten
oder react angular ist business factory manager singleton pattern observer kram angular ist zu
plotted für kleinkram sage ich als jemand der noch nie was mit angular gemacht hat ja also die
zwei die zwei würde ich dir empfehlen wo mein persönlicher favorit ja das ist aber aber react
ist eindeutig das verbreitetste von allen also react ist mit abstand das verbreitetste
sondern nach angular und dann ungefähr gleich auf view würde ich sagen was übrigens auch schön
ist bei javascript frontends frontend frameworks die letzten jahre über dass sich da nicht mehr
so viel tut also nicht also es ist nicht jede jede woche ein neues hip framework angesagt das
ist zwar immer noch so dass es bei javascript quasi jeden tag neue frameworks gibt und die auch
gewissen gewisse fahrt aufnehmen immer auf github aber so bei den großen drei frameworks da tut
sich die letzten drei jahre schon relativ wenig es ist entweder angular react oder view und gerade
mit view 3 muss man sagen ist das simpel zumindest so was ich jetzt als jemand der nicht viel mit
react gemacht hat aber so sieht es für mich so aus als ist view 3 relativ nah dran an dem wie es
react schon immer gemacht hat also wenn man die composition api von von view verwendet gut und
angular ist halt bloated as fuck so es gibt noch jede menge jede menge anderen sachens welt ist
auch total angesagt aber ich würde dir empfehlen eins von diesen drei mein persönlicher tipp
wäre view oder react angular ist zum einstieg vielleicht jetzt nicht so das beste javascript
und schön in einem satz ich finde die sprache an sich ist ist natürlich auch wichtig aber gar
nicht mal so entscheiden weil javascript kannst du halt so schön verbiegen und view hat das halt
schön verbogen so dass es gut gut benutzbar ist ich habe keine ahnung was das ist aber das mache
jetzt nicht auf angular ist ein bisschen wie gesagt habe damit nie groß was gemacht angular
ist ein bisschen sowie ruby on rails der kram muss so heißen wie sich das die angular entwickler
gedacht haben ja bei ruby on rails war es das gleiche weiß ich weil weiß ich hab vielleicht
das ist wahrscheinlich ein boomer talk ich ich hab ja noch mal ich hab ja in der zeit schon web
anwendung gebastelt wo ruby on rails noch angesagt war ich glaube weiß ich wie viele von euch schon
mal was mit ruby on rails gemacht haben aber da war das auch so das zeug musste so heißen also
controller mussten immer bla bla bla irgendwas dings controller heißen oder hört mir jetzt
gar kein anderes gescheites beispiel zu ein ja oder auch diese datenbank x wie hieß das noch mal
bei ruby on rails action action wie ist das datenbank zeug bei ruby on rails irgendwas mit
action glaube ich action record kann das sein ich weiß gar nicht mehr genau ja da musste auch da
musste auch alles ganz exakt so heißen dass ruby on rails das erkannt hat und ich glaube bei
angular ist es ist es ähnlich die coolen kids nennen das an angela was an angela ach was auch
immer was die coolen leute sagen die coolen leute sagen auch nicht ubuntu sondern jubantu was
eigentlich viel falscher nicht sein könnte der brätselsnack hat angeschrieben 7 monat subscription
ja typescript ist so ein ding ich habe typescript schon verwendet hat es version 0 0 8 oder so
was gehabt das war so ich habe das damals damals mir angeguckt wirklich als es ganz ganz frisch
war als weil das der ehemalige c-sharp-lead-designer einen talk drüber gegeben hat das ist der gleiche
typ dahinter und da habe ich das damals ausgebildet fand das ganz cool aber ich verwende es aktuell
gar nicht es ist lustig ich habe es ich habe es verwendet da war das noch ganz neu überhaupt
nicht cool zwar so die zeit war alle gesagt haben ja ja nice aber wozu ja kann ich alles in ja was
machen aber jetzt wo das richtig mainstream ist mit typescript mache ich eigentlich so gut wie
nix damit guck dir mal mind an ist eine was eine dsl für webdef beziehungsweise ist das
irgendwas ist das irgendwas wo ich dann in jaml hinschreibe wie meine webseite aussehen
sollen oder so was finde ich so was finde ich auch schon immer bei diesen ganzen server konfig
frameworks bisschen fragwürdig deswegen finde ich ja ansible eigentlich ganz gut weil das immer
noch recht prozedural von oben nach unten ist und nicht und nicht ganz so abstrakt von dem was unter
der haube passiert mich wundert dass das net framework noch platz eins hat wo meinst jetzt
hier in der umfrage nebo auf was bezieht sich das jetzt mind programming language habe ich
noch nie gehört mind lang bisschen wie dat ja dat ist auch die überflüssigte sache hat
irgendwie einer eine sinnvolle erklärung dafür warum sie für flatter dat genommen haben und
nicht einfach javascript oder meinetwegen auch go wenn es vor google ist man hätte auch gleich
eine ordentliche programmiersprache nehmen können ich verstehe nicht warum ja das was
ich von dat bisher gesehen habe ist auch ist durchaus in ordnung aber sie laut aber ich
verstehe nicht warum also wo das sinn davon ist dass man eine eigene sprache genommen ist
gerade weil go so angesagt ist ja aber hätten sie ja mit go auch
ja aber genau das kannst du mit go auch machen gut ohne ohne shit
aber go läuft auch so gut wie überall drauf ja ich weiß nicht so genau keine ahnung
warum auch immer
ja das stimmt schon aber bei go ist ja alles schon da also nicht als hätten sie das jetzt
neu bauen müssen klar ganz viel web zeug gerade im cloud bereich ist mittlerweile go
voll angesagt aber ich gehe mal ja ich gehe da voll kannst ruhig posten aber ich gehe
davon aus die haben da schon ihren kund kund gehabt naja why flatter uses dat oh oh ne das
les ich mir jetzt nicht durch aber ich glaube es euch dass sie einen kund dafür gehabt haben
dass mir jetzt zu viel aber ja haben die tldr obendrüber ne ne gibt's nicht aber ja dass
sie einen kund dafür gehabt haben gut bei google bin ich mir da nicht so ganz sicher
wie ist das gilt bei google hier bei google bin ich mir da nicht so ganz so sicher ob
das immer sinnvoll ist was sie treiben also bei google hat ja nur wirklich schon viele
dinger fabriziert konnte man das nicht nach ja sortieren lassen viele dinger fabriziert
die nicht so durchdacht waren google chrome apps sind weg ok habe ich gar nicht mitbekommen
hat auch kaum einer verwendet ok das ist das allererste angela gs das das habe ich tatsächlich
mal ein tutorial durchgemacht das aber auch so ziemlich das einzige das hat ja wohl mit
dem aktuellen gar nichts mehr zu tun
das meiste habe ich noch nie was von gehört beispielsweise google bookmarks wussten die
mal dass es überhaupt existiert anderen graben kennen fitstar yoga pp hans das haben die
bestimmt aufgekauft fitbit und fitstar und dann haben sie gesagt jetzt vorbei rip
kann mich noch dran erinnern mal auf dem uralt android tablet war dieser Mist mit installiert
und wollte unbedingt dass ich mich anmelde naja ich würde sagen fangen wir mal an nix
gegen stadia ja nix handfestes aber stadia keck weight alter
programming language for writing single page applications und warum genau braucht es dafür
eine eigene programmiersprache und eigene functions und eigene class libraries und eigene
was auch immer und mal auf shithub gucken wie beliebt das ist aber für javascript projekte
nicht so beliebt also also alle javascript projekte unter 15.000 sterne sind nicht beliebt
das ist ist leider echt so bei anderen projekten ist 3.500 sterne saumäßig beliebt aber javascript
nicht alles unter 10.000 sterne ist bei javascript nicht beliebt kann ich euch auch beweisen
guckt mal wir machen jetzt mal search nach language ging das überhaupt noch search nach
javascript und dann nach stars mit mindest mit mindeststern machen wir 5.000 so search
natürlich gibt es die aber sonst die nicht geben muss ich muss ich mal ein größer 5.000
so guckt mal hier 188.000 sterne react 175.000 sterne bootstrap jetzt glaube ich sogar mittlerweile
ohne jQuery 153.000 sterne also man sieht alles unter 10.000 sterne wir gehen jetzt mal auf
die seite 100 es ist einfach unter 10.000 sterne ist kannst du vergessen es ist nichts
dabei guckt euch das mal an ist doch der wahnsinn also man muss echt sagen wisst ihr warum kam
man hier nicht ordentliche page geschichten machen dass ich wenigstens eine page eingeben
kann wo ich sagen kann ich will page wenn ich kann hier oben sagen page 30 aber das
ist doch usability pur guckt euch das mal an also selbst guck mal das hier ist ein repos
mit 14.000 plus sterne ich hab davor noch nichts gehört keine ahnung keine ahnung
irgendwas altes das habe ich glaube ich schon mal irgendwo gelesen keine ahnung keine ahnung
nie gehört nie gehört nie gehört nie gehört das habe ich gehört das ist das ist outdated
das benutzt keiner mehr das war mal ein package manager für frontend libraries das verwendet
keiner mehr heute verwenden alle ganz normal npm oder jahn oder was ist denn gerade noch
so angesagt eine zeit lang war npm wurde gehatet alle haben gesagt ja besser als npm und dann
haben sie v2 rausgebracht und keiner und keiner wollte das mehr und dann weiß ich nicht was
jetzt angesagt ist wahrscheinlich einfach npm snap nee deno ist wieder was ganz was
anderes deno ist quasi node.js in rust was gab es eine frage was github ist also ich
bin kein informatiker aber was macht man mit github du teilst deinen sourcecode mit der
restlichen welt wenn du irgendwas programmiert hast kannst du den sourcecode auf github hoch
laden und es kann jeder daran mitbauen der will oder gucken wie du das gemacht hast oder
kommentare schreiben oder fehler melden oder einfach nur ein stern geben weil es ihm gefällt
das ist quasi so das facebook für programmierer ist vielleicht nicht der beste vergleich
weil facebook ist boomer shit das instagram für programmierer vielleicht eher ohne bilder
kenne ich alles nicht was ist das das habe ich schon mal gehört wie gesagt benutzt keine
ahnung was das ist keine ahnung keine ahnung keine ahnung kuh wenn die buchstaben für
die libraries ausgehen kuh ja kein stimmer keine ahnung keine ahnung also doch das kenne
ich das ist eine template geschichte das das kenne ich tatsächlich nie gehört nie gehört
nie gehört nie gehört achso doch kenne ich testin das kenne ich auch nie gehört nie gehört
nie gehört nie gehört also bullshit generator guck mal der bullshit generator hat 15.000
sterne auf github warum ah ja na jetzt ist alles klar also denke ich denke schon dass
der hat es glaube ich schon verdient es scheint jetzt auch nicht so alt so groß zu sein oder
der bullshit generator ok ich habe keine ahnung was der typ 3 aber aber er hat 15.000 github
sterne warum nicht warum warum denn nicht ich gönne ihm seine github sterne das habe
ich glaube ich schon mal irgendwo verwendet warum braucht man denn extra warum kann ich
aber fetsch verwenden was ich nie gehört nie gehört nie gehört nie gehört nie gehört
discord gs das das habe ich glaube ich habe sie gesagt also im prinzip alles unter 10.000
sterne javascript libraries sind nicht beliebt was programmierst du denn so ist ja aktuell
ehrlich gesagt ich glaube wir haben heute noch nicht eine zeile hingeschrieben aktuell
bin ich am schwätzen aber heute machen wir das was im titel steht weil es wird bald kalt
und ich muss endlich meine heizung ein und ausschalten können von meiner von meiner
heim automatisierung aus dass es prinzipiell geht aber das letzte mal schon ausprobiert
das ist das ist schöne schöne tages topic punkt ja ja ich würde sagen wir fangen jetzt
auch mal an wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben ich glaube wir haben das letzte mal so gut
für nichts gemacht weil ich auch gesagt habe wir machen entspannungs stream und wir haben
da nichts gemacht so also ich muss mich mal kurz auf meinen raspberry pi verbinden wobei
ne muss ich gar nicht also ich habe ein raspberry pi im keller stehen für alle die sich fragen
wie ich an meine heizung dran komme ich habe ein raspberry pi im keller stehen und ich
habe so einen kabel am raspberry pi dran so ein kabel das kommt vorne in die heizung
und kann dann mit zwei infrarot leds kommunikaten mit der heizung das ist ein neues kabel das
ist das ist ein kabel sagen wir also es ist ein kabel was jetzt funktioniert das alte
hat ja nicht mal richtig getan genau so das heißt wir greifen auf den raspberry pi unten
im keller zu und schicken dem kommandos was der machen soll so und ich muss mal kurz gucken
wo wir stehen geblieben sind wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben ja ach ja und um an die heizung
sachen zu schicken muss man so tolle muss man so tolle befehle verwenden get temp ww
ist also nicht dass ihr denkt ich habe mir das ausgedacht oder so die steuerung von der
heizung hat so komische wobei das auch falsch ist es ist nicht wirklich die steuerung von
der heizung sondern die implementierung von diesem heizungs protokoll verwendet das halt
also sprich das habe ich mir nicht ausgedacht da müsst ihr mich nicht hauen für für diese
komische englisch englisch deutschmischung also zum beispiel mit get temp ww ist kann
ich die warme wassertemperatur aktuell abfragen oder get betrieb art kann ich aufmachen genau
ich kann wir gucken ob es jetzt funktioniert was ich was wir da gebaut haben das letzte mal
test aha interessant ok ich weiß nicht mal was ich gebaut habe deswegen kann ich auch
nicht mal nachvollziehen ob es funktioniert das natürlich auch ist natürlich auch ganz toll
fest was habe ich denn gemacht hier run zehnmal was zum kw return true warum was habe ich da habe
ich irgendwas erklärt das letzte mal oder sonst können wir alles rausschmeißen warum auch immer
ich was was habe ich denn warum habe ich hier überhaupt warum führe ich das ganze noch mal
10 10 mal aus ich wollte gucken ob der ich weiß wieder ich wollte gucken ob der das
ordentlich cute alles selbst wenn ich multis red darauf zugreifen ok ok verstanden verstanden
verstanden ok get temp ww ist was haben wir denn das letzte mal gebaut wie funktioniert
das wie funktioniert der kram noch mal das weiß ich doch das weiß doch jetzt nicht mehr
kommentare sind prinzipiell overrated noch mal eine dumme frage zu recht bzw view ist das so
was wie bootstrap nein also bootstrap ist ja auch keine javascript library bootstrap ist
mittlerweile ist das ja auch komplett jquery 3 und sowas bootstrap ist eine user interface
komponenten library hauptsächlich css und für die funktion ein bisschen javascript also bootstrap
ist gui gedöns hauptsächlich css und view beziehungsweise react sind javascript frameworks
über web anwendung guckt ihr guckt ihr mal die die vgs beispiel an dann sieht man es eigentlich ganz gut
heizung die mit dem chat kommunizieren kann das könnte man das könnte man tatsächlich machen aber
ich will nicht meine heizung vom chat steuern lassen was habe ich denn hier gebaut ich blick
da überhaupt nicht mehr durch also endpoint so endpoint ist die ip vom raspberry pi ok das
das das verstehe ich alles klar halt genau heizung nach youtube views wenn ich wenig views im monat
habe gibt es keinen strom für die gibt's gibt's wird nicht mehr gibt's keine werbe mehr von der
heizung ip leak oje oje schon wieder huge ip leak erst erstmal hacker man machen auf 192 168 1129
heizung nach kontostand naja nachdem ich nie geld ausgebe wäre es hier immer übelst warm
ich weiß wo dein haus und ja hier ja auf port 3002 ich gebe echt kein geld aus leute ich weiß
nicht das einzige was ich mache ist ab und zu wenn wenn ich mich dazu entschieden habe mal irgendwie
was weiß ich ich brauche neuen rechner oder irgendwie sonst was dann kaufe ich einmal ein
bisschen was größeres aber sonst ich gebe nie geld aus ich glaube ich sterbe irgendwann mal mit
irgendwie was ich viel auf dem konto
machst du urlaub selten also so richtig so richtig urlaub irgendwo an strand fahre ich selten warm
und strand ist eh nicht so meins island fand ich ganz fand ich ganz nice aber das mache ich auch
nicht so oft also ich gebe eigentlich ich gebe eigentlich kein geld aus
das komplette gehalt in stonks ja das sollte ich das sollte ich eigentlich machen dass es
nicht weniger wird mit der zeit komm mit nach norwegen nordlichter anschauen ja und händchen
halten oder norwegen ist aber auch nice norwegen würde ich mir auch mal wieder geben nicht wieder
norwegen würde ich mir auch gerne mal geben du hast dein geld wirklich auf dem konto liegen ja
das liegt da wo es ankommt einmal auf meinem business konto und einmal auf meinem privaten
konto wo ich monatsgehalt drauf kriege zum größten teil nicht alles wieso patrick fährst du fährst
du nach norwegen oder warst du in norwegen also ich das ist auch was würde ich mir auch mal
gerne angucken ich fahre jetzt nicht mit oder so aber das ist auch was ich mir prinzipiell mal
gerne angucken würde jetzt kommen hier die finanztipps ich empfehle den a1 jx 52 etf
eats money das werden gringer ich habe gar nichts ich bin wenn es danach geht total der kacken loop
überhaupt nichts alles ich leute alles in ich glaube da kann man nichts falsch machen
doch wo sind wir denn jetzt hier stehen geblieben ich versuche gerade zu verstehen was ich da letztes
jahr gebastelt habe ich letztes mal nicht letztes jahr ich habe ja gut wie gesagt ab und zu kaufe
ich mir sowas wie den klo mit spülung und sowas also mit poppers spülung nicht spülung wie man
das kennt ich lasse den chat eignen kaufen ich glaube das funktioniert nicht so gut oder aber
es funktioniert gut dann gibt es als nächstes den den stock champ da darf da kann man dann das
aktien kaufen an den chat crowdsourcen das wäre das wäre der hit so also was habe ich denn hier
gebaut sekunde ich muss mich mal kurz konzentrieren ich muss mir irgendwas machen wie bekommt man
wischl studio für linux gar nicht das ist nicht wischl studio das ist rider wo wir gerade beim thema sind gibt es updates
wollte ich jetzt eigentlich gar nicht machen ich wollte eigentlich nur gucken ob es updates gibt
konnte man das nicht mal ordentlich minimieren also alles in gamestop ja also was habe ich denn hier
gebaut so ich wollte ich wollte testen ob ich get temp ww ist und get betriebsart abfragen kann was
habe ich was habe ich denn hier gebaut also also endpoint das ist die ip so dann gibt es hier
eine endlosschleife die commands einliest und dann sage ich queue command und write das in die
schleife ich queue überhaupt nichts das ist das ist fake da macht überhaupt nichts das jebaited
ja der macht überhaupt nichts der gibt einfach nur test aus anstatt das wirklich abzuschicken
was ist denn das hier also geht das aber nicht erst mal aus irgendwelchen gründen diese schleife
daraus wozu auch immer ich die da reingebaut hat man weiß es nicht so hast du schon mal data
clip benutzen nö ich habe nie gemacht so ich will jetzt erst mal gucken was kommt dann bei get temp
also ich muss das noch mal kontrollieren was ich da letztes mal gebastelt habe was kommt denn
bei get temp ww ist und get betrieb art raus wie fühle ich wie fühle ich das denn jetzt überhaupt
aus was habe ich denn hier gebaut ok try right ich glaube so ich glaube so ist das gedacht
glaube so ist das gedacht was ich hier was ich hier gebaut habe ok ich schaue mal mal ob das
funktioniert was ich jetzt gemacht habe queue commands so und wo kriege ich jetzt hier die
ausgabe hier also mal schauen mal schauen ob das irgendwas halt big sinnvolles rauskommt ja das
ist jetzt zwei wochen alt das ist legis ok es scheint zu funktionieren es scheint zu funktionieren
leute also get get temp ww ist ist 51,4 0000 2 grad Celsius also ist wirklich derjenige der die
ausgabe und die kommandos da sich ausgedacht hat er gehört wirklich geschlagen ich meine was ist
das denn get temp ww ist und dann so eine ausgaben formatierung das ist doch wirklich absoluter
pains jam das ist bestimmt ein rundungsfehler ja denke ich auch so und get betrieb art ist ww
ww bedeutet warmwasser also es gibt als betriebs art für die heizung es gibt ww das ist warmwasser
und es gibt h plus ww das ist heizung plus warmwasser ok ich glaube ich habe wieder
verstanden was ich das letzte mal gebaut habe alles klar gut warum habe ich das denn so umständlich
gemacht mit queue und allem warum habe ich das denn so komplett so umständlich gebaut das letzte
mal ich weiß es ich weiß es das ist das ist dass der in einer tcp session mehrere kommandos
ausführen kann ne ja ja ja ja ja verstehe
ja ok ok ich glaube ich glaube ich habe wieder verstanden was ich was ich hier gebaut habe also
der verbindet sich zum raspberry pi zu der adresse hier der verbindet sich zum raspberry pi
öffne den netzwerk stream setzten read write timeout und dann nimmt er jedes der kommandos
die hier reingeschmissen wird und liest das ergebnis davon aus was macht er alles in einer
tcp session weil es dann schneller geht ok ok ok das habe ich das habe ich verstanden die
sache ist nur die wie bekomme ich denn jetzt die antwort hier wieder raus glaube das war nicht
sonderlich durchdacht was ich da gebaut habe ich sollte das hier in extra klasse verpacken und
dann so eine unkompleted callback oder irgendwas in der richtung einbauen aber das machen wir
heute nicht wir bauen heute an einem anderen teil weiter weil die eigentlich also das heizung
auslesen dass das weiß ich jetzt wie es funktioniert ich muss gucken wie ich in mein home assistant
ein button bekomme beziehungsweise wie ich mein home assistant mein meine heizung discover lassen
kann das das probieren das probieren heute mal aus also weil home assistant hat so ein eigenes
discovery protokoll für geräte über mqtt und man kann wenn man das richtig formatiert also wenn
man das so hier macht so wie hier beispielsweise ein beispiel drin ist leider ist halt das beispiel
von denen ziemlich ziemlich abfack also wenn man so was hier schickt dann erkennt das home assistant
als eigenes gerät und man kann dem sogar mit liefern was es für ein gerät ist also ich könnte
zum beispiel home assistant sagen hallo ich bin ich bin gerät a und ich habe einen sensor einen
schalter und einen weiteren temperatursensor und sowas das heißt ich könnte das schön zusammen
kopieren als ein gerät mit fünf sechs verschiedenen sensoren und schalter das muss ich jetzt probieren
ob ich das hinkriege diese die weiß die weiß discovery also wir tun jetzt einfach mal so
als wüsste ich als als wüsste ich was meine heizung für eine aktuelle temperatur also
weiß doch was für eine aktuelle temperatur hat current temp ist was machen wir einfach mal
51 51 grad ja ich weiß jetzt nicht ob man das später als int oder als als drink braucht
oder wir können wir können auch water water temp können auch ganz ausschreiben ist aber
wurscht so und jetzt versuche ich mal den sensor irgendwie anzulegen im mqtt in home assistant
so so da irgendwie so dass er das erkennt da bin ich jetzt ja mal gespannt ob das hinhaut
also wie macht man wie macht man die weiß discovery denn so braucht man ein beispiel
also schlechter formatiert hätten sie das jetzt ja nicht schreiben können das hier meine
ich das hier meine ich genau create new sensor manually also das da will ich machen ok das
probieren wir jetzt aus das probieren wir jetzt aus also wir machen das ganze mal über
command line und schauen mal ob das funktioniert also mein ziel ist jetzt dass ich es schaffe
dass meine heim automatisierung neues gerät erkennt schauen wir mal mqtt admin kleck 3d
alles klar sub ok meine credentials stimmen schon mal also message wie macht man das denn
jetzt home assistant binary sensor garden config wir machen einfach mal das beispiel
das ist das topic das ist das topic funktioniert doch im leben nicht was ist wenn ich das jetzt
einfach abschicken passiert dann schon irgendwas natürlich nicht das wäre auch zu einfach
wie geht das denn jetzt ok ich kopiere einfach mal diesen mist damit wir machen wir machen
einfach mal das beispiel also name garden device class motion state topic bei ja meinetwegen
so hat er jetzt was erkannt nö das tschibet nicht mal das beispiel funktioniert noch nicht
mal das beispiel geht so wie sollte wie sollte der dann heißen der sensor der sensor sollte
heißen garden ok naja qta ist am start gut ja das kann übrigens gar nicht funktionieren
was ich hier gemacht habe lull ja du hast recht es sind zu viele zu viele quotes so geht
das jetzt wahrscheinlich sagt gar da ist er beim binary sensor garden jawoll aber hier
hat er kein device drinstehen warum aber immerhin hier garden wunderbar dass das da die welt
gebraucht so und wie löscht man das jetzt wieder den sensor sending empty message ok
das heißt ja aber den garden sensor wenn ich den jetzt löschen will dann schicke
ich das hier nur mit empty message hat nicht funktioniert doch hat funktioniert nice alles
klar so ok das ist aber noch nicht alles weil ich muss nicht einfach nur den binary sensor
anlegen ich muss dem sagen dass es zu meiner heizung gehört so und dazu muss jetzt sagen
device discovery device da weiß ich halt nicht wie es funktioniert device class ich
habe irgendwas mit identifier im hinterkopf identifier ok das ist wahnsinnig aussagekräftig
die hilfe seite identifiers home assistant mqtt google hilft uns google google hilft
uns identifizier gibt es nicht einfach mal in den example für edding devices exemplar
example muss es doch irgendwas geben discovery muss es doch irgendwas für geben also ich
weiß dass es funktioniert ich habe das auch schon mal mit karl ausprobiert aber das ist
schon so lange her keine ahnung mehr amqt device da können wir uns bestimmt abgucken
wie die das machen library provides tools so simply jawoll was ist das für eine sprache
ist rast ist rast ne c++ das c++ oder ist das sauce muss das sein das ist die einzigen
beispiele die wir finden identifiers das versteht auch wieder kein mensch was der typ da treibt
was zum identifier ist da nicht ein example für meine güne muss noch was zu finden sein
das war ich ich kriege das nicht mal zusammen die weiß identifier das ich kriege es nicht
mal richtig zusammen wie das wie das home assistant selbst sagt schreibs in die jamme
ne ne ne ne home assistant sagt nicht schreibs in die jamme weil ich weiß ja noch gar nicht
was ich für ein gerät habe was ich in die jamme schreiben kann das sollte ja discover
das geht das geht das kriegen wir alles das kriegen wir hin ich brauche nur mal ein ordentliches
beispiele wo man das sieht haben die vielleicht eine erklärung dafür identifier in dem wir
das über die discovery ich muss nur rauskriegen wie das funktioniert aber vielleicht war es
in der history dazu schon identifier nein leider nicht wie ging das denn noch mal also
wie man das prinzipiell anlegt haben wir ja verstanden das war ja gar nicht so kompliziert
das steht ja hier gibt es hier noch irgendwas mit aber was kann man denn hier noch alles
anlegen name die weiß glas state topic es gab irgendwas wie die weiß da bin ich mir
ziemlich sicher ich habe das ja schon mal gemacht vor eine weile also mal mal karl ausprobiert
das hat funktioniert muss es doch ein gescheites beispiel für geben home assistant mqtt discovery
die weiß identis heißt irgendwas mit identifiers das weiß ich noch sorry leute flash bang achte
warum ist denn meine flash bang und schlafe ich ein identifier nein wo steht denn das
wie das geht ok wir machen jetzt wir machen jetzt trick 17 wir lassen jetzt lasst mal
habe ich irgendwas was ich discover lassen kann wo ich einfach mitschneiden kann was
es macht wirst jetzt nicht was zumindest nichts was hier irgendwie dran kommt an an diese
interne testkiste nähe ich habe es hier nicht in der history drinstehen das habe ich nicht
im stream gemacht das kenne ich die seite kenne ich da steht aber nichts so drinnen
wie es funktioniert das ist die seite die kenne ich
das war irgendwie das war sinngemäß irgendwie sowas ich gucke mal ob ich das noch irgendwie
hab halbwegs aus dem kopf zusammen kriegt das war irgendwie sowas die weiß dann nochmal
einen sub wie auch immer und dann da drin so was nochmal wie name und dann gab es nochmal
identifiers und das war dann ein array aus noch irgendwas ganz ganz wir war das deswegen
brauche ich mal ein beispiel dafür fast mal auf vielleicht hat es jetzt funktioniert
das hat noch nicht mal angelegt natürlich ich habe eine idee wir können uns wir können
uns einfach an den an den fehler meldung lang hangeln wo er sagt dass das nicht passen
kann schau mal wie wer led oder das motor das man genau das würde ich auch immer konnte
man sich hier nicht locks angucken normalerweise hatte man hier so ein drop down für für für
unterschiedliche sorten locks das jetzt weg ist es jetzt wo anders
es gab doch hier normalerweise auch locks wenn es bei der discovery nicht funktioniert
ja ich könnte mir auch diese c++ library angucken das problem ist immer ziemlich schwierig
aus source code der jam der jason zusammen baut rauszufinden wie dann das jason an sich
aussieht vielleicht haben die hier ja irgendein example drin ich muss mal kurz haben doch
normalerweise locks waren aber ich leute ich muss mal kurz parallel schauen auf meinem
live home assistant ob es da auch so aussieht ne da kann ich hier da kann ich hier locks
durchschalten da gibt es mehrere sachen locks da kann ich zum beispiel auch vom vom core
mir die locks angucken und dann sieht man auch discovery fehler wo ist das hier warum
gibt es das hier nett warum gibt es das hier nett wo sind die locks normalerweise ist hier
ein button normalerweise ist hier ein button wo man umschalten kann zwischen was er anzeigen
soll was wir starten jetzt wir starten das ding jetzt einfach mal neu configuration start
einfach die komplette vm neu lull bamm nochmal neu starten das ding nein nein nein ich versuche
kein element mit id zu finden versuch über die home assistant discovery ein device zu
discoveren das nicht einfach nur ein device sondern was halt zu einem also mehrere sensoren
die zu einem device gehören so dass es in der discovery auftaucht da muss ich erstmal
ein beispiel für finden so neu starten neu starten schatten die was ok wir haben hier
die gleiche ip wie vorher alles gut mal reloaden da sind wir wieder home assistant hat restartet
hä warum zum teufel habe ich hier keine locks mehr ich habe gerade geguckt bei mir im live
ich habe hier locks ich kann hier unterschiedliche locks auswählen zwischen was ich sehen will
muss ist das jetzt ist das jetzt woanders oder so aber wir können abdehnen ok ich abdehne
mal vielleicht vielleicht ist vielleicht ist das problem dann gefixt jaja ich habe ein
bisschen älterer wir brauchen update aber brauchen kein backup siehst was willst du
von mir wo ist das problem das ist die offizielle installation man warum geht das nicht
reload jawoll restart jawoll
auf error vor was was willst du von mir
ist ist die docker container registry gerade daun oder was oder wo ist das problem haben
die irgendwas verkackt haben die irgendwas verkackt ok da müssen wir mal kurz nach der
hilfe suchen das ist eigentlich nicht das was ich jetzt machen wollte und kann install
failed ok wir brauchen glaube ich ein bisschen mehr update fehlt wo stand jetzt was mit unauthorized
das steht aber auch nicht immer da ja warum geht das nicht ja genau und was hat er was
hat er denn sonst noch verschmerzen das scheint ja alles zu stimmen
try restarting home assistant das ich habe gerade ganze vm neu gestartet scheint ja äußerst
komplex zu sein warum geht das nicht ein ich meine ich habe ich ich habe das offizielle
image genommen dass der shit einfach geht ich meine weißt du was ich jetzt mache ich
ich restart das ding jetzt doch noch mal aber das ist ja bescheid reboot haus ich start
ich mache jetzt gleich das ssh addon drauf und guck ob das funktioniert guck mal hier
wie schnell der restart huge high speed hast du internetanbindung in der form a das ist
eine gute frage aber ich wüsste nicht warum nicht sagen wir so ich installiere mal das
ssh addon wobei ich das wahrscheinlich an install ja ich muss ja internetanbindung haben
sonst hätte ich ja gar nicht dass das mqtt addon und zeug installieren können aber
und mal gucken ob ich habe er uns installieren kann ssh wie ist das schell die terminal wie
ist denn dieses ssh addon home assistant ssh addon ssh und webterminal genau das das meine
ich ja das brauche ich musste man das noch adden das ist schon so lange her dass ich
letzte mal gemacht habe enable advanced user mode jawoll advanced the advanced user mode
jawoll endlich ssh ach so war das ssh und webterminal wahrscheinlich geht das installieren
jetzt auch nicht was will der denn von mir haben die gerade haben die gerade bei github
irgendwelche probleme haben die irgendwelche schmerzen gerade bei bei github bei der container
registry ne das ist kein dns problem es ist zwar alles irgendwie ein dns problem aber
das glaube ich kein dns problem shit hub home assistant das ist in in versucht mal das image
neu runterzuladen soll ich da neu runterladen das ist ein fertiges vm image mit allem was
man braucht ich meine ich kann das neu runterladen und neu installieren dann habe ich die neue
version aber das ergibt ja keinen sinn dass das nicht funktioniert fails to update irgendwas
ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung was das ist wir gucken jetzt mal ob die leute auch
irgendwelche schmerzen haben die woche nein das sind keine beispiele drinne für das was
ich machen will da ist nur ein beispiel drin wie man ein device hinzufügt nicht wie man
quasi ein root device mit mehreren sensoren zu geordnet zu einem bei dir geht es auch
nicht ja dann liegt das nicht an mir dann ist dann generell grad irgendwas im arsch
gut dann können wir nichts upgraden was nicht so schlimm ist dann mach hier ein update das
geht wahrscheinlich aber auch nicht jetzt ob das jetzt geht habe ich so meine zweifel
os ging kor nicht ach stimmt vielleicht sehe ich jetzt die locks connection rebooted da
jetzt gerade da rebooted ok also das os update hat schon mal funktioniert dann haben die
gerade probleme mit ihren repos dann liegt das nicht an mir wenn das wenn das dann nicht
funktioniert ja stimmt jetzt habe ich advanced mode an vielleicht sehe ich jetzt die locks
genau genau das ist eine gute idee und die sind ja auch schon auf github umgestiegen
nicht mehr auf die docker registry die docker registry haben die haben ja komische beschränkung
eingeführt in letzter zeit auf starte gibt alles vm aber wir haben es geschafft
ok mal gucken ob er jetzt anzeigt
beim home assistant vm jaja das ist alles das ist das offizielle image von den für
vm da drinne ist dann glaube minimal was ja worauf besetzen die denn jetzt auf demian
keine ahnung dann docker docker shit kram der normalerweise aber relativ gut funktioniert
so also supervisor system ah jetzt kann ich die locks auswählen ok guck mal da sehe ich
jetzt nämlich auch was ich verkehrt mache mit meiner discovery aber anscheinend was
auch immer aber ok upgraden upgraden kann ich nicht weil es gerade kaputt ist das liegt
nicht an mir ist aber nah geht es jetzt wieder war das nur was temporäres
war das nur was temporäres vielleicht ane shell login top macht der was wer hat sich
denn gedacht dass das eine gute farbe ist wer ist denn auf die Dinge gekommen anstatt
das einfach nur schwarz weiß zu machen ok dann macht anscheinend wirklich was
jetzt hat jetzt funktioniert jetzt jetzt ging es jetzt ging es ok das war wirklich irgendwas
temporäres das lag das lag nicht nicht an uns jetzt kann ich bestimmt auch jetzt kann
ich bestimmt auch den kram installieren sensor with mal multiple values ne ne das ist nicht
das richtige das ist nicht das richtig das das muss irgendwie so aussehen zusätzlich
die weiß musst du irgendwie angeben und dann irgendwie identifiers so muss das irgendwie
aussehen das ist ja alles nicht drin das ist ja auch ein sensor mit mehreren values ich
brauche keinen sensor mit mehreren values ich brauche ein gerät was mehrere sensoren
hat und schalter und so ich weiß ich weiß prinzipiell wie es aussehen muss aber ich
finde keine beige kein richtiges beispiel dafür autoturn mqtt und hin into a device ok das
das klingt doch schon mal ganz viel versprechen ja das ist es das brauche ich endlich warum
muss man so warum muss man sich so ein beispiel genau identifiers nehmen das brauche ich warum
muss man sich so einen krab aus aus dem forum suchen kann ich sein ok jetzt gucken wir uns
mal an ob es ankommt also jetzt jetzt kann ich das noch mal neu ausprobieren mal test
weil sie hinschreiben so warum warum kommentiert das eigentlich nicht aus so wie das ausführen
irgendwie zsh config also was was mache ich denn jetzt hier falsch ich muss sagen das
ist ein sensor das ist ein was weiß ich gar ich will ja gar nicht als das garden heißt
ja das ok wir bleiben bei dem standard beispiel wir bleiben bei dem stand das funktioniert
sondern was machen die da jetzt die weiß das mache ich auch die weiß name mache ich auch
richtig ich habe identifiers falsch geschrieben oder nee identifiers habe ich das falsch
geschrieben ob ihr paste das jetzt einfach aber ich habe das nicht gequotet guck mal
daran wird es wahrscheinlich sagt bloß ich habe alles richtig gemacht aus dem kopf und
habe quats vergessen mal sind wir jetzt hier stehen geblieben da config nee nicht funktioniert
also gut da kommt man jetzt mal die hilfe nicht die hilfe an die fehlermeldung an was
habe ich denn jetzt hier verkackt gar nichts
malerweise sollten hier die fehler drin stehen was was was ist denn jetzt hier falsch also
ich nehme mal das ganze beispiel von dem kerl wo habe ich denn monka es habe ich schon wieder
zugemacht leute wo habe ich wo habe ich hab es doch eben gerade gefunden wo ist es welches
tab ist es da da alles klar ok also so so ist an so ist es angeblich richtig wir testen
mal ob das funktioniert einfach wenn ich das so mache wie der typ das hier geschrieben
hat das funktioniert mit den quotes schon mal garantiert nicht kann man hier nicht gescheit
raus copy pasten ja die quotes sind sind sind sind sehr komisch ist das denn für komische
geht das für komische quotes dann schreibe ich schreibe das jetzt doch noch mal von hand
also gar ein config sensor so die weiß also wir machen es jetzt mal in der reinfolge auch
wie dieser typ hier alles weg also das ist das wissen wir dass es funktioniert ok
unique id unique id brauchen wir glaube ich noch ja natürlich wir brauchen das das kann
ich mich auch noch wir brauchen irgendwie unique id weil er ansonsten das glaube ich
nicht erkennt weil weil wenn mehrere sensoren zu einem die weiß hinzugefügt sind braucht
das ding irgendwie in der eigene id ok so und dann macht er was die weiß so hier das
da das ist das eigentliche wichtige das da brauchen wir das hier was bei die weiß drin
steht also die weiß so neues objekt auf identifiers das gibt ein eigenes array so das ding heißt
dann was weiß ich lull wie auch immer ist egal ein identifier name lullw nur dass ich
nicht doppelt hab so wie ich mich kenne moment das stimmt ja auch nicht doch oder ja ok dann
macht er noch garagestorm model manufaktor das brauche ich alles net ok der hat es jetzt
auch gepusht ok hoffentlich geht das jetzt da ist es das lullw die weiß es hat funktioniert
jawoll da ist es sehr schön sehr schön sehr schön sondern jetzt kann ich nämlich jetzt
kann ich jetzt kann ich auch erzählen wofür das da ist der erkennt jetzt ein gerät und
hier würden die ganzen sensoren stehen die zu diesem gerät hören gehören das heißt
man kann das jetzt kopieren so wie ich das vorhin gemacht habe und so wie das bei denen
auch in der offiziellen seite drin steht legst du quasi ein gerät pro sensor an und das will
ich ja gar nicht ich will ja ein gerät anlegen was mehrere sensoren drinne hat das ist viel
besser ich weiß nicht warum die hilfe seid so kacke ist so das ist das doch schön also
jetzt wissen schon mal dass das im prinzip so funktioniert so wie wie füge ich da jetzt
sensoren hinzu das hätte er eigentlich doch jetzt erkennen müssen hier unten müsste doch
jetzt eigentlich ein sensor drin stehen no entities ok also jetzt hat er schon was discovered
und dann muss jetzt erstmal man entstand setzen dass das dass das funktioniert garden oder
ich musste die weiß klasse setzen das kann natürlich auch sein wobei habe ich das nicht
hier gesetzt die weiß klasse die weiß klasse motion doch unique it garden im der sollte
jetzt eigentlich erkennen dass das die weiß einen motion sensor hat wenn ich das richtig
verstehe das sollte normalerweise hier drunter stehen aber ich finde schon mal gut dass der
das die weiß erkannt hat da bin ich schon mal froh so löschen wir das mal wieder habe
ich denn jetzt hier verkehrt gemacht ich glaube die reinfolge ist egal auch ich hier das mit
der unique id muss ich mal kurz gucken ob man das ob man das wirklich braucht das braucht
man nicht so jetzt muss ich mir noch mal das beispiel angucken von dem typ oben ok also
was hat was macht der denn jetzt der macht name die weiß klasse der macht name das habe
ich auch die weiß klasse motion habe ich auch state topic home assistant binaries das wird
auch stimmen state topic da hat er eben noch unique id drinne ok vielleicht braucht vielleicht
braucht man das wirklich ich füge ich füge das noch mal hinzu unique id was weiß ich
als champ das allein hatte nix gebracht warum taucht denn der sensor jetzt nicht auf muss
man vielleicht wirklich noch noch was setzen für den sensor dass da drin steht habe ich
jetzt irgendwas nicht drinne was der typ noch drinstehen am model manufactor das ist doch
eigentlich vollkommen egal egal schau mal das hier developer assist links aha oh jetzt
jetzt wird es abgedreht ja genau is binary sensor nicht true falls ja ja ist ist es auch
ja ist es aber ich setze ja noch keinen keinen status aktuell vielleicht muss ich wirklich
den status pushen dass es drinne steht ich meine die hätten einfach ein jason beispiel
hin machen können oder warum haben wir nicht einfach ein jason beispiel hingeschrieben
anstatt diesen grämpel hier
mach mal switch anstatt binaries sensor binaries sensor ist ok das ist das einfachste was man
haben kann ich push jetzt einfach mal nen state zu
meinem binaries sensor binaries sensor state on so hat es jetzt was der erkennt gar kein
sensor da dran was habe ich denn vergessen lass mal hier gucken ob es ob das jetzt bei
entities
warum steht er da jetzt doppelt drinne
ich ich ich kopiere mir jetzt wirklich ich kopiere mir jetzt wirklich mal das testing
da rein von dem typ
was war das identifile rf bridge genau
ne war mal wo ist wo ist das beispiel von dem kerl noch mal da
pick binaries sensor ich mache jetzt einfach mal
pick binaries
Das war's für heute.
$1,80
Das war's für heute, das war's für heute, das war's für heute, das war's für heute, das war's für heute, das war's für heute, das war's für heute, das war's für heute, das war's für heute, das war's für heute.
Das war's für heute.
Das Modell kann doch auch weg.
Manufaktor braucht kein Diggo.
So, mal gucken, ob das jetzt noch funktioniert.
Ah, der Heiz-Champ, da ist er.
Ah, GitHub Packages.
Okay, vielleicht liegt es daran, dass es nicht funktioniert.
Alles klar, okay.
Ah, hier, guck mal, hier ist jetzt auch mein Sensor.
Hier ist jetzt auch mein Sensor.
Das heißt, wenn ich den jetzt einschalte, das müssen wir jetzt ausprobieren.
Wenn ich den jetzt einschalte, mal angenommen, irgendjemand drückt unten auf der Heizung an Ausknopf.
Gibt ja zwei Möglichkeiten, entweder man macht es über das Webinterface oder man macht es über die Heizung selbst.
Dann sage ich jetzt hier Binary Sensor on und zack, er ist an.
Ja wunderbar.
Okay, ich glaube, ich habe jetzt halbwegs verstanden, wie der ganze Kram funktioniert.
Guck hier, Sleep 2 und jetzt schaltet alle an.
Bäm.
Gut, gut, gut.
So, ich glaube jetzt, meine Güte, das ist aber schon echt big brainst.
Aber das hier ist übrigens, nice, wer auch immer das gepostet hat.
Ich weiß nicht, wer war es denn hier, der Chillfreak hat es gepostet.
Das ist sehr hilfreich hier.
Das brauche ich, genau so was.
Okay, hey, ich weiß wenigstens, was ich jetzt bauen muss.
Nice.
Excellent, excellent.
Okay, noch mal einen anderen Test.
Wir machen jetzt kein Binary Sensor.
Ach komm, wir programmieren das jetzt.
Also ich weiß jetzt ja im Prinzip, wie es aussehen muss.
So.
So muss es aussehen zum.
Kann man das vielleicht ein bisschen, ein bisschen Zeilen umbrechen, da ich da irgendwas
Gescheites noch erkenne.
Okay, das heißt wir brauchen jetzt erstmal ein MQTT Klein für.NET.
Da gibt es, da gibt es einen ganz guten.
Nehm ich den da.
Den verwendet der Preis Champ auch unter der Haube.
Ich wusste, ich wusste nämlich nicht, was ich für eine Message Q verwenden sollte für
den Preis Champ und der Crawler, den ich dafür verwende, der kann bloß eine MQTT Klein
für.NET verwenden.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich für eine MQTT Klein für.NET verwenden soll.
Der Crawler, den ich dafür verwende, der kann bloß MQTT.
Das heißt, ich verwende auch MQTT.NET, dass meine Crawler Server an den Frontend
Ausliefer Server schicken können, wenn was verfügbar ist.
Aber das sproken sehe ich gerade.
Übrigens Leute, ich weiß nicht, ob von einem von euch hier noch das den Kram verwendet.
Der Preis Champ geht glaube ich Ende des Monats offline.
Ich habe keinen Bock mehr neue Geräte reinzubasteln und die Verfügbarkeit ist eigentlich wieder
ganz ok.
Ich glaube Ende des Monats ist Schluss mit dem Preis Champ.
Ich sage es nur schon mal.
Du schaust jeden Tag rein.
Ich meine, ich kann es auch.
Ich kann es auch weiter laufen lassen.
Es ist jetzt nicht wirklich, als dass das irgendwie bei mir viel Aufwand verursachen
würde.
Es kostet mich halt im Monat irgendwie 40.
Ne.
Erst mal überlegen, was kostet es mich denn im Monat?
Ich glaube 40 Euro oder so.
Drei Triple Core Crawler und eine Frontend Kiste.
Ich glaube 40 Euro oder so kostet mich das.
Ich meine, zu viel vom Geld her nicht mal, aber ich werde da halt wahrscheinlich nie
wieder was dran machen.
Ok, also wir brauchen MQTT.net.
MQTT.
Wie alt bist du eigentlich?
Ja, ich bin 37 und benutze ReLive Twitch Emoji.
Ja, man muss mit der Zeit gehen.
MQTT.net, Manage Client, die zwei Sachen brauchen wir hier.
Vielleicht reicht es auch, wenn man das installiert, das hat den Rest die Abhängigkeit mit installiert.
Agila Boomer, so sieht es aus.
MQTT.net, Manage Client, Examples.
Also wir machen jetzt das da, was wir hier auf der Kommandozeile in vielleicht nicht
ganz gut lesbare Art gemacht haben, machen wir jetzt mal in.net.
Also da müssen wir uns erstmal verbinden.
Wie funktioniert der Kram?
Ich muss echt hier den Darkreader aus.
Kann man GitHub Dark Mode einschalten ohne eingeloggt zu sein?
Geht das?
Ich glaube das geht nicht, oder?
Ich glaube man muss eingeloggt sein, ich sehe hier nämlich nichts für.
Ok, muss doch einschalten.
Nee, ich glaube Dark Mode schaltet man im Profil ein und ich habe ja kein Profil.
Brauchst du alle Topics des Devices?
Ich leg die Topics ja selbst fest.
Ich will.
Oh, das sieht Business-Stronk-mäßig aus.
Das MQTT Client Factory.
Warum ist das so kompliziert?
Warum kann ich nicht einfach sagen New MQTT Client und das geht also gar mit der Standard
ESP32 MQTT Library einfacher.
Warum ist das so anstrengend zu verwenden?
Ich habe den Client noch nie verwendet, muss ich sagen.
Ich habe den MQTT Server verwendet und der ist ganz ok.
Ok, Copy Paste.
Auf geht's.
Alles importieren.
Das ist ja der neueste Shit gerade.
Das macht Microsoft auch gerne.
Also wenn ihr euch mal irgendwelche ASP.NET Sachen von Microsoft anguckt, das sieht alles
so aus mittlerweile.
Ja, Bilder-Pattern, genau.
Ich denke mir halt so.
Warum?
Ich meine, ist es wirklich so schwierig zu sagen?
Sowas hier?
Nur so irgendwie.
Ja.
PW.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
So, mein.
Ist das zu kompliziert?
Ist das zu einfach wahrscheinlich?
Ist das zu einfach?
Er muss doch sowas machen.
Also.
Auto Connect Delay.
5 Sekunden.
Ja, ok.
Client Options.
Client ID.
Heiz-Champ.
Leute, was ist besser?
Heizung-Champ oder Heiz-Champ?
Der Heiz-Champ ist glaube ich besser, oder?
Der Heiz-Champ.
Schauen wir mal.
1, 9, 2, 1, 6, 8, 1 Punkt.
1, 2, 9.
Port?
Muss man hier?
Nee.
Port?
Nee, das geht nicht.
Also hier darf ich schon so hinschreiben.
Der Heiz-Champ.
Der Wärme-Champ.
Ja, der Wärme-Champ, ich habe immer Bedenken, wenn die Umlaute drinne haben.
Dass es irgendwie rumspackt.
Ich nenne es lieber Heiz-Champ.
Temp-Champ.
Temp-Champ ist auch nicht besser.
Nicht verkehrt.
Das hört sich aber nach Temporä an.
TLS.
Lul, alter.
Lul.
Als würden wir hier irgendwas verschlüssen.
Bild?
Bild.
Was zum?
Jetzt wird es aber übertrieben.
H.S.
Joho.
21 Monate.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Falscher Knopf, oder?
Guck mal hier.
Du brauchst einen Managed MQTT Client Options-Bilder.
Und dann brauchst du einen MQTT Client Options-Bilder.
Nochmal.
Nee.
Ah.
Das ist ein Managed Client Options-Bilder.
Und das ist ein Client Options.
Die spinnen doch, oder?
Man kann es auch absichtlich kompliziert machen.
Ja, da platzt der Kopf.
Mag ja alles seinen Sinn haben.
Aber warum die so?
Wobei, wir können das rappen.
Wir rappen das gleich einfach.
Wir machen daraus ein Public Class Simple MQTT Client.
Wir rappen das.
Und dann mach ich das so, wie ich das will.
Aber erst mal kurz gucken, ob das überhaupt klappt, was ich hier bastle.
Also, MQTT Factory Create New Managed Client.
Ja, gut.
Und wegen...
Ach so, wie mache ich das hier mit Passwort überhaupt?
Passwort?
Authenti...
Ah.
With Authentification.
Hä?
Was soll das sein?
Message Byte Array.
Alles klar.
Jetzt kommt der Auth-Bilder gleich.
Genau.
Hä?
Moment, ich benutze bestimmt das Falsche.
With Credentials.
Das klingt doch auch nicht...
Ah, okay, okay.
Ich habe nichts gesagt.
Also, Username.
Aber glaube ich, Admin, oder?
Admin.
Jawohl.
Passwort.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Alles klar.
Okay.
Meine Güte.
Ähm.
Okay.
Blablabla.
Bild.
Jetzt brauchen wir eine MQTT Factory Create Managed MQTT Client.
Subscribe, Ess...
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Ich will einfach was publishen und gucken, ob es ankommt.
Ich will einfach nur was publishen und gucken, ob das hier unten erscheint.
Also.
MQTT Client.
Publish.
Gut.
Das funktioniert.
So, schau mal.
Await.
Publish.
Application Message.
Kann ich nicht einfach sagen?
Topic?
Doch.
Topic.
Hack.
Und Message.
1, 2, 3.
So.
Und wenn das jetzt alles funktioniert, dann sollte es hier unten jetzt auftauchen.
Oh.
Was?
Call Start Async.
Ach so.
Ah.
Ich kack noob.
Guck mal da.
Ja.
Okay.
Das hat nicht funktioniert.
Wetten.
Der ist rausgegangen aus dem Programm.
Bevor er es schicken konnte, weil es hier doch nicht wartet, bis es publisht ist.
Nee.
Ah.
Moment.
Ich bin ja auch dumm.
Lol.
Leute.
Warum sagt...
Chat.
Warum sagt mir das denn keiner?
Das hier ist nicht der MQTT-Server.
Das hier ist der Raspberry Pi im Keller, der sich zur Heizung verbindet.
Aber das ist ja falsch.
So.
So ist richtig.
Ah.
Es funktioniert doch trotzdem nicht.
Ach.
2.
Da ist erinnert mich an die FISBUS Enterprise Edition.
Ist echt so.
Das ist total übertrieben.
Was die hier gebastelt haben.
Ja.
Hahaha.
Man kann es mal ganz echte übertreiben.
Ah, jetzt geht's, ok. Alles klar, nice. Publish, gut. Jetzt bestimmt auch ohne das Warten
hier. Ne, echt nett. Ist aber ziemlich mies. Der wartet gar nicht. Guck mal, der wartet
mit dem Publish nicht. Ich muss hier wirklich noch ein Readline reinmachen. Das ist ja schon
fail. Ok, aber ich muss halt mal ehrlich sagen, also die Handhabung gefällt mir ja wirklich
gar nicht. So, was ist das denn hier? Egal. Komm, wir wrappen das jetzt mal so, dass mir
das besser gefällt. Simple MQTT Client. So, also wir brauchen einen Konstruktor, der will,
also Konstruktor will haben ein Endpoint Server, ein Port. Irgendwie sowas. Was ist der Default
Port? Default Port ist 1883. MQTT Default Port, ich glaube 1883. Ja, steht doch schon.
Auch standardmäßig leer, falls man das nicht braucht. Und, ne, ich Passwort. User, standardmäßig
leer und Passwort standardmäßig leer. So, weil jetzt kann ich den ganzen Crampel nämlich
anstatt das hier, naja, geh mal kurz hier weg. Jetzt kann ich das nämlich einfach so anlegen.
Wir verschieben das jetzt mal in ein eigenes File. Ah, das kann der noch nicht. Guck mal,
ist Ry damit überfordert, wenn man, wie heißt denn das diese, also wenn man die Files nimmt
ohne diese Class-Main-Geschichten drumherum, wie heißt denn das offiziell bei denen, weiß
ich gar nicht. Das ist ja neu seit dem letzten oder vorletzten C Sharp, dass man sein Main-Programm
ohne irgendwelche Sachen einfach in der Datei reinschreiben kann. Ok, dann legen wir es
hier mal an. Also New Class Simple MQTT Client. IP-Adresse als die Sharp-Klasse benutzen, ne,
wir benutzen was anderes. Zeig dir auch gleich was. Wir benutzen an der Stelle wieder ein
IP-Endpoint und dann kann man sich nämlich auch den Port sparen, weil er steckt dann
da schon mit drin. Ok, jetzt kann ich das nämlich in meinem Main-Programm einfach so
anlegen. War MQTT Client gleich New MQTT Client Endpoint. Nein, nein, nein, nein. Was? 1221682.133
und dann Password Admin als User Admin Password 123.56. Das ist doch deutlich schöner als
dieses andere Gedöns, was ich da vorher machen musste. So, jetzt muss ich noch gucken, dass
ich das hier ordentlich wrapen alles. Options, Import, Import, Client Factory, wunderbar.
Na ja, mach mal, importier mal alles. Start Async, ja gut, Awaiten im Constructor funktioniert
nicht, aber ich muss es auch nicht Awaiten. Einfach starten und dann startet er halt, wenn
er gestartet hat und gut ist. So, das ist doch jetzt schon viel, viel schicker als die
andere Geschichte. So, jetzt brauche ich noch irgendwie eine Möglichkeit, was zu publishen.
Schön den Bilder in Bilder weggewrappt, ja. Ich meine, was ist das hier? The fuck? Bilder,
Bilder. Hier fehlt wahrscheinlich doch Credentials-Bilder, die gibt es bestimmt auch noch. Ah, fast.
Echt, genau, Credentials-Bilder gibt es auch. Gibt es vielleicht auch noch. Ok, also Public,
Async, das brauchen wir wahrscheinlich jetzt. Task, Pub, einfach nur Pub, wir machen das
ganz kurz und knackig. Publish, uploaded, fünf Buchstaben gespart, gibt Bonuspunkte.
Publish, so, wir wollen Publishen, String, Topic, String, Message, fertig. Wir wollen
keine Bites oder sowas publishen, wir wollen einfach nur Strings publishen, sonst nix. So,
ähm, achso, den sollte ich mir vielleicht mal speichern, hab ich noch nicht. Fuck.
So, MQTT-Client, was hat er hier für Schmerzen? Is always assigned before used. Jaja, das
ist jetzt nicht mehr. MQTT-Client, Publish, Topic, Message. Das ist jetzt relativ kurz,
aber mein, warum soll ich mehr nachbauen, als es eigentlich sein müsste? So, und das
soll's eigentlich gewesen sein. Die IP solltest du aus den Parametern, nehmt das richtig,
das ist ziemlich bescheuert, die da zu verwenden. Kann man hier vielleicht direkt nen Endpoint
eintragen? Ernsthaft jetzt? Ein MQTT-Client TCP-Options-Bilder, wirklich? Ist das euer
Ernst? Was soll ich noch alles bilden? Oh man, hör mal auf, ey. So, ich brauch mal kurz
eine andere Playlist. Oh ne, so anstrengend. Ja, hier, wunderbar. Wupp wupp wupp. Die übertreiben
es jetzt echt. So, IP-Endpoint, doof, dass man das nicht einfach übergeben kann. Hallo?
Kann man das, das weiß ich gar nicht, kann man das two-stringen und es funktioniert?
Kann man den Endpoint two-stringen machen und es kommt was richtiges raus? Das weiß
ich gar nicht, muss ich jetzt mal kurz ausprobieren. IP-Endpoint, pass, ja, 1111, 3002, was auch
immer. So, und jetzt two-stringen. So, was kommt denn da jetzt raus? Kommt jetzt was
ordentliches raus? Aha, guck mal, das, das muss ich sagen, das ist wirklich was, was
ich an der.NET Standard Library mag. Die macht in der Regel das, was man erwartet
und das ist eigentlich so das Höchste, was man wollen kann, dass der Mist sich einfach
so verhält, wie man das haben will. Ja, Client-ID sollte ich auch übergeben und
hier sollte ich vielleicht auch nicht Hardcoded reinschreiben, sondern User und PW. So, Heiz-Champ,
Client-ID, komm, krieg da auch noch hin, Nathan. Client-ID, Client-ID, tja, gut. Die Client-ID
sollte ich vielleicht gar nicht optional machen. Braucht man überhaupt eine Client-ID? Ist
aber ganz bescheuert, braucht man eine Client-ID? Geht bestimmt ohne. Da soll er sich in eine
random Client-ID ausdenken, ist mir doch egal. Die Client-ID juckt mich mal absolut gar nicht.
MQTT Client, hopp. Await, da haben wir ja gelernt, das funktioniert, das reicht nicht,
deswegen muss ich tatsächlich noch mal ein Readline dran machen. Hopp, keck, null. Mal
schauen, ob das jetzt publisht. War ich nicht dabei, als das gepublished. Funktioniert nicht.
Warum nicht? Es ist broken. Welchen Sinn hat der ganze Bilderkram? Ich weiß es nicht genau.
Also, normalerweise hat es, Moment, wo sind wir denn hier? Also, normalerweise hat es
den Sinn, also das ist die Geschichte, das hat sich Microsoft mal ausgedacht. Ich glaube,
das ist entstanden, vermute ich mal, bei ASP.NET Core als Host-Builder. Da konntest du, bevor
du deine Web-Anwendung überhaupt, also bevor du den Web-Server deiner Web-Anwendung überhaupt
startest, konntest du dem ein paar Optionen mitgeben. Und damit du nicht eine Instanz
quasi erstmal anlegen musst, die du danach per Optionen customisest und es relativ komplex
war, sich das zusammenzubauen, hat Microsoft sich einen Host-Builder überlegt für ASP.NET
Core, wo man dann zusammenbauen konnte, so was weiß ich, auf welchem Port soll der ganze
Kram laufen, wohin soll es loggen und solche Geschichten. Also im Prinzip ein Web-Server-Config.
So, und es gab dann halt Entwickler, die ja fanden das so geil, dass sie es jetzt halt
überall reingebaut haben. Funktioniert Start Async im Constructor? Ja, das funktioniert,
solange man nicht awaiten will. Aber mir ist es ja egal, wann es gestartet ist. Hauptsache
es ist gestartet. Wobei, jetzt wo ich es gerade sage, vielleicht ist mir das gar nicht egal.
Geht es deswegen nicht. Ich mache nochmal die Client-ID, vielleicht will der ohne Client-ID
wirklich, wie ist das Ding Heiz-Champ? Der Publisht nichts. Warum Publisht denn der gute
nichts? Muss ich wirklich auf den Start warten? Das ist zwar nicht schön, aber ob es daran
liegt? Hä? User und Passport sind leer? Nee, User und Passport sind nicht leer. User und
Passport stehen hier drinnen. Äh, warum geht das jetzt nicht? Was hat der jetzt für Schmerzen,
warum geht das nicht? Hä? So schwer ist es doch jetzt wirklich nicht gewesen, was ich
hier gebaut habe. Port? Port ist Default. Ach so, warte mal, was kommt denn hier raus,
wenn ich kein Port angebe? Was kommt denn hier raus, wenn ich kein Port angebe, Zack?
Ja, okay. Ja, das ist aber dumm. Das ist aber dumm. Das ist aber doof. Funktioniert
er immer noch nicht. Nee, was war das? MQD-Default-Port. 1883. Warum geht denn das jetzt nicht? Das kann
auch gar nicht sein, dass es nicht funktioniert. What the fuck, da hat sich doch überhaupt
nichts dran geändert. Okay, warte mal. String, Server. Okay, weg damit. So, jetzt ist es doch
exakt das, exakt das, was ich, ach so, was ich, was ich das letzte Mal auch hatte. Bloß
kann doch nicht sein, dass man mit so einfachem Kack sich so lange aufhält. Der publisht
einfach nix. But why? Warum publisht er nix? Der verbindet sich überhaupt nicht. Ich habe
hier irgendwas verkehrt. Der verbindet sich erst gar nicht. Okay, mal checken. User. User.
Pw. Kann doch jetzt ernsthaft. Das kann doch jetzt nicht sein. Server verbindet sich dahin.
Ich mache jetzt extra einen Wait hinten dran, dass er das nicht macht. Konsolen-Debugger,
beste. So, Moment, machen wir das noch mal weg. Jetzt geht's. Hä? Was habe ich jetzt
anders gemacht? Ich habe den Port weggemacht. Ich blick nicht mehr durch. Man kann da gar
kein, man kann da kein Port angeben. Kann das sein? Wie gebe ich, wie gebe ich hier
den Port an? Port? Der will den Port an der Stelle nicht haben. Kann man hier vielleicht
auch ein Port angeben? Mit dem Portbilder. Genau. Jetzt habe ich es verstanden. Ja, okay,
dann machen wir das. Dann machen wir das doch so, wie ich mir das ursprünglich gedacht
habe. Port 1883. Komm, wir machen das so, ich glaube. Ich glaube, da kommen wir am besten
hin. Okay, jetzt sollte es aber endlich funktionieren.
Ach, jetzt denkt er, dass das der Port ist. Okay, dann muss man es halt direkt. Übrigens,
das ist ein Feature, was C++ bis heute noch nicht hat. Named Arguments, also eigentlich
eines der wichtigsten, der wichtigsten Dinger überhaupt. Aber haben die sich gedacht? Nope.
Da kann man viel zu sehr lesen. Die haben keine Named Arguments. Das kann man jetzt ja tatsächlich
direkt lesen, fast sogar noch. Fast sogar noch besser als vorher. Das Gefühl meiner
Maus spackt wieder ein bisschen rum. Das wäre es jetzt nämlich echt gewesen. Nach zwei
Wochen oder so. Naja, aber scheint jetzt zu funktionieren. Gut, also nachdem wir jetzt
die Basics aus dem Weg haben, die eigentlich noch weniger als Basics sind, können wir
das verbinden. Alles klar. So, jetzt kann ich versuchen, diesen Kram mal in mein Home
Assistant zu exportieren. Den da. Oh, Delete. Jawoll. Geh weg. Also, wir haben ein MQTT Client,
verbinden uns Passwort, wie auch immer. Publish. Ich würde sagen, wir brauchen eine JSON Library,
da nehmen wir einfach das Standard Ding, was ja Microsoft selbst nicht mehr verwenden möchte.
Wir haben jetzt ja System Text JSON oder sowas. Aber ich finde Usability mäßig ist das immer
noch am besten. Aber ich habe ein Video gesehen in.NET 6, was wir eigentlich verwenden. Also
könnte man das wirklich mal ausprobieren..NET 6, New JSON API. Es gibt jetzt neue,
es gibt jetzt in.NET Extension Sachen für JSON, dass man JSON.NET nicht mehr braucht.
JSON Note Pass. Ich habe das aber noch nie verwendet. Keine Ahnung, wie das funktioniert.
Kann man das hier importieren? Wir probieren das jetzt mal. Wir probieren das jetzt mal aus. Im
Titel steht.NET 6. Also probieren wir jetzt auch mal was.NET 6 mäßiges aus. Also,
deinstallieren wir das wieder. JSON Schreiben ist mit Newtonsoft immer noch einfach. Hast du auch
das.NET Zeug schon ausprobiert, das.NET 6 Zeug? Weil das, also bisher habe ich auch immer gesagt,
das ist abartig as fuck, die neue JSON API. Aber mit.NET 6, das ist angeblich besser geworden.
New JSON Object. Guck mal hier. India. Das probieren wir jetzt mal aus. New JSON Object.
Das Alte konntest du nicht schreiben. Mit.NET 6 haben die jetzt was Neues, eine neue JSON Geschichte
obendrauf gebaut, wo man auch sich Objekte zusammenbauen kann, weil sie selbst, habe ich in
einem Webcast gehört, weil sie gesagt haben, sie sehen immer noch, dass viele Leute JSON.NET
verwenden, weil die Handhabung noch nicht auf gleichem Niveau ist. Deswegen haben die jetzt
so Dinge hier eingelegt. Das probieren wir jetzt aus. Im Titel steht.NET 6. Wir müssen jetzt
aber was.NET 6 mäßiges ausprobieren. Also New JSON Object. Was brauchen wir denn da? So, also wie
muss man das jetzt schreiben? Muss man das so schreiben oder kann man auch, muss ich mal ausprobieren,
kann man auch sowas hier machen? Age gleich 29? Nein, nicht. Okay, man muss das, ah noch,
doch anscheinend schon. Property Name Node Value. Also kann ich jetzt hier zum Beispiel sagen,
Keck W und dann Value, ach nee Value, Komma. Ah, das geht.
Ich wäre nie im Leben anhand dieser Parameter drauf gekommen, dass man das so schreiben muss.
Skill Killer, das verstehe ich auch nur zum Teil. Die Begründung von Microsoft, warum sie JSON.NET
nicht wollen ist, ich vermute erstens, weil sie den JSON.NET Typ eingekauft haben fürs ASP.NET Team
und zweitens, weil sie gesagt haben, es ist zu langsam. Also sie sagen ja ihre JSON Implementierung
gerade was für Web Anwendungen, was ja bei ASP.NET eben auch wichtig ist, wäre das JSON,
Newtonsoft JSON zu langsam und das neue viel besser. Wie kommt man auf die Idee, dass das
ist? Ist das die offizielle Schreibweise für einen Key Value Pair zum Initialisieren oder so? Das
habe ich noch nie gesehen, noch nie wusste ich nicht, dass das möglich ist, an der Stelle das
so zu schreiben. Also das heißt im Endeffekt, ich kann jetzt hier sowas machen, probieren wir
das doch mal aus. Wir bauen jetzt mal den Kram zusammen. Also Name, Name ist Eater. Gute Frage,
ich habe in meiner Ausbildung, dass in der letzten Woche oder in den letzten paar Tagen habe ich drei
Jahre Ausbildung zusammen randomize Word Dokument mäßig und dann irgendwie fragt
mich nicht 150 Seiten oder so ausgedruckt und daraufhin hat mein damaliger Ausbildungs,
oder einer der Leute, die mich ausgebildet haben, nicht mal mein Chef damals, hat gesagt,
weißt du was, scan meine Unterschrift ein und hau es einfach überall drunter. Der hatte
keinen Bock den Kram zu unterschreiben. Der hat einfach gesagt, weißt du was, passt schon,
mal scan meine Unterschrift ein und haut runter. Hat auch geklappt, wobei die IHK gesagt hat,
sie fanden meine Ausbildungsberichte nicht gut, aber nachdem die Präsentation gut war und meine
Prüfung gut war und alles insgesamt gut war, haben die gesagt, weißt du was, geh heim, alles ist gut.
Also Name Heater. Als nächstes kommt State Topic. Aber diese Schreibweise von Key Value Pair
Initialisator habe ich noch nie gesehen. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt sowas hier mache,
da kommt ein Key Value Pair raus. Nee, das geht natürlich nicht. Dann verstehe ich es nicht. Dann
check ich diese Schreibweise hier nicht, das ist mir zu hoch. Das muss ja so eine Art Key Value
Pair Initialisator sein, was ich hier mache. Aber ich kann da auch mehrere angeben. Wie geht das denn?
Moment, das hier ist irgendeine Collection, oder? Das ist doch irgendeine Collection. Das ist
irgendeine Dictionary Collection oder so. Mal kurz gucken, wie das überhaupt funktioniert.
Das Berichtsheft ist maximal unnötig. Na ja, hm. Ja gut, das hier ist ja einfach nur diese
Initialisator-Geschichte. Aber woher weiß der denn, dass das hier quasi sowas wie Add Range ist?
Das muss ich mir nochmal angucken. Das könnte ich für eigene Sachen auch ganz gut verwenden.
Also, Heater State Topic brauchen wir als nächstes. State Topic ist das da. Was aber so nicht stimmt,
das muss ich... Oh, das wird lustig. Das muss ich zusammenbauen. Weil State Topic, das muss
ja Unix sein pro Gerät. Das heißt, ich muss irgendwas mit meiner Mac-Adresse oder so bauen.
Also, State Topic muss dann quasi Sensornahme. Theoretisch müsste es sein Sensornahme. Das können
wir jetzt in der Lehrstelle gleich ausprobieren. Das müsste dann sowas sein wie Sensornahme. Heißt
dann, keine Ahnung, in dem Fall jetzt... Heizung. Das müsste dann sein sowas wie Sensornahme. Aber
davor müsste dann noch irgendwie in Unix irgendeine ID kommen. Irgendetwas Randomizedes oder Mac-Adresse.
Davor müsste dann noch eine ID kommen, weil ansonsten funktioniert das Ganze ja nicht.
Ich mache mal... Nee, nee, nee, nee, das funktioniert nicht. Das funktioniert nicht,
weil es muss bei jedem Neustart die gleiche ID generiert werden. Sonst hätte ich auch
Randomized irgendwas genommen. Da bietet sich die Mac an, an der Stelle, würde ich sagen.
Bei was bei mir haben die Prüfer sich die Berichte letztes Jahr sogar angeguckt und
zu Fragen gestellt. Tja, bei mir nicht. Client ID. Ja, die Client ID ist echt nicht verkehrt,
die könnte ich nehmen. Wobei ich eher sagen würde, die Client ID setzt sich zusammen
aus... Nee, das sollte irgendwas... Bin nicht ganz sicher, ob wir das machen können. Da
bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher. Bei den Client ID muss ich ja Hardcoded vergeben, was aber
kein Problem ist, weil das würde ich ja einzigartig machen. Schauen wir mal. Probieren wir mal
aus. Xiaomi. Also, wir machen mal Sensor ID, Mac. Kommt da noch irgendwas rein? Also,
das ist das Date Topic. Ich will einfach nur probieren, ob das Chasing Zeug jetzt funktioniert.
Was im Topic drin steht, ist total egal. Naja, das stimmt schon, aber das ist insofern nicht
egal, dass ich das Topic selbst wieder finden muss. Also, wenn ich dann später da was reinpushen
will, muss ich das ja irgendwie logisch mir selbst wieder zusammensetzen können. Und
es muss jedes Mal das Gleiche sein. Also, ganz so random kann das nicht sein, weil sonst
kann ich es, wie gesagt, später selbst nicht mehr erraten. Also, ich muss ja, wenn ich
irgendwann ein Update pushen will, muss ich mir anhand Sensornamen zusammenreimen können,
ach, wie ist denn jetzt das Date Topic gewesen. Wir machen dann eh eine Sensor Klasse dafür.
Mal schauen, mal schauen. Ich will jetzt erst mal gucken, wie dieses Chasing Zeug funktioniert.
Random UUID mit festem Seed. Oh, das ist eine coole Idee. Aber dann kann ich auch mal eine
Mac nehmen. Ich meine, Unica wird es nicht. Probier das gleich mal mit meiner Mac aus.
Aber das muss ich mal, aber das ist eine gute Idee. Das ist eine gute Idee. Ich probier das
mal gleich mit meiner Mac aus. Aber jetzt erst mal das Chasing Zeug zusammen. Also, State
Mac haben wir. Unique ID jetzt an der Stelle. Gut, das ist ja wieder was anderes. Das ist
jetzt für den jeweiligen Sensor. Also, das ist jetzt vorbei. Unique ID. Braucht man die
überhaupt? Moment. Braucht man die überhaupt? Das kann doch selbst irgendwas generieren.
Das ist mir doch egal, was der da macht. Alter, ich treff den noch nicht. Ok, doch, die braucht
man anscheinend. Ok, die Unique ID braucht man. Ja, die muss sein an der Stelle. State
Topic nutzt man eigentlich nicht, aber da schreiben die sogar hier, guck mal. Hier, State Topic.
Die schreiben das sogar in ihrer offiziellen, äh, Dings da, dass man das benutzt. So, Unique
ID. Ja, das würde ich sagen, ist wieder sowas hier. ID und uns Sensor Name. Sowas da. So,
dann brauchen wir als nächstes. Ah, jetzt. Ok, jetzt wirds interessant. Wie funktioniert
es jetzt, dass ich da drin noch was eigenes anlege? Kann, muss ich jetzt sowas hier machen?
Gleich New JSON Object. Ah, guck doch mal da. Das ist, ich muss sagen, das, das benutzt
sich doch recht angenehm bis jetzt, wenn das denn, wenn das denn funktioniert. So, dann
kommt jetzt hier Identifiers. Wie pasten wir das mal? Identifiers. Gleich. Und jetzt brauche
ich einen Array. New JSON Array. Hoffentlich geht das so. Kann ich da jetzt gleich, kann
ich da jetzt gleich schon irgendwas reinschreiben? Items. Heitschamp. Ja, ich könnte ID aber
wirklich einfach Heitschamp machen. Ich mein, mehrere Heitschamps gibt es ja nicht. Das
würde, also beispielsweise würde ich das jetzt auf irgendeinem ESP laufen lassen, auf
irgendeinem Micro, dann wäre das ziemlich doof, weil dann müsste ich ja den Source Code
jedes Mal anpassen, wenn ich fünf Controller hab. Aber so, den Heitschamp gibt es nur einmal.
Ich hab ja auch nur eine Heizung. Aber vielleicht, ich guck mal gleich, wie man das mit Mac-Adressen
auslesen macht. Das interessiert mich tatsächlich. Da bin ich mir sehr unschlüssig, wie das
funktioniert. Das muss ich mal ausprobieren. Hab ich glaube ich noch nie, noch nie gemacht.
Ok, also. New JSON Array, der Heitschamp. Ok. Und jetzt brauchen wir noch Name. Und dann
mal gucken, was da für einen JSON rauskommt. Name. Sag mal, warum autocompleted er wie verrückt
hier? Pappe halten. Name. Das ist jetzt der Name für das Device. Das ist auch Heitschamp.
Ok. Und jetzt gehen wir das mal aus, JSON. Mal gucken, ob die das toString überladen
haben, sodass es standardmäßig funktioniert. Kommen wir mal. Ha, haben sie. Tatsächlich,
guck mal, da kommt jetzt was Sinnvolles bei raus. Name, Heater, State, Topic, Unique.
Das sieht ziemlich gut aus. Das sieht tatsächlich so aus, als könnte das funktionieren. Ok,
da bin ich mal gespannt. Also, MQTT Klein, Publish. MQTT Klein, Publish, JSON, toString
und Topic. Ah ja, gut, hier. Das stimmt übrigens überhaupt gar nicht, was ich da mache. Das
ist nicht das State Topic. Blablabla, Home Assistant, Binary Sensor. Es ist nicht Config.
Es ist das totaler Schwachsinn, was ich hier reingeschrieben habe. Das kann doch nicht
funktionieren. State. Slash State, nicht Slash Config. Slash State. Aber pushen, pushen muss
ich das Ganze auf das Topic hier. Config. So, mal schauen, ob das jetzt funktioniert.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt. Mal gucken, ob das jetzt hier auftaucht als Gerät. Fack.
Das wäre jetzt auch zu einfach gewesen. Ok, er hat aber schon mal gepusht.
Das sieht auch eigentlich ganz gut aus, oder?
Das sieht doch eigentlich ganz ok aus. Was ist denn jetzt da falsch dran?
Topic ohne Variablen. Hä? Wie?
Was? Wo? Hä?
Ne, das sieht doch richtig aus. Das ist doch ok.
Darf man da vielleicht kein Underscore haben oder so?
Du übergibst das Topic falsch. Ich sehe es nicht.
Ist doch hier genau, ist doch eigentlich richtig. Ja, State Topic. Achso. Ah, lull. Ja, der Chat
hat es wieder gesehen. Natürlich, kann ja nicht funktionieren.
Da ist er, der Heiz-Champ. Wunderbar, funktioniert.
Heater ist off. Jetzt auch gewundert, wenn nicht.
Ok, sehr schön, sehr schön, sehr schön. Also das funktioniert schon mal, das Gerät
so anzulegen. So, und jetzt wollte ich mal gucken, ob ich
irgendwie die Unique-ID raus bekomme. Mit Mac-Adresse und sowas.
Könnte sowas funktionieren. Lass mal überlegen.
Wie kriege ich meine Mac-Adresse raus? Lass mal ausprobieren.
Stack Overflow..NET Core Mac-Adresse Interface.
Network Interface, get all network interfaces. Das klingt gut.
Reliable method. Ah ja, hier, guck mal da. Das sieht doch gut aus.
Ah, wir treiben es jetzt mal hier nicht. Also, machen wir hier mal den unteren Kram weg.
Network Interface, get all network interfaces. EF, ach ne, ach das ist dumm, nennen wir es.
Nee, wir sind unter Linie unseres ETH. Gibt es eine ID von der Wiesmann Anlage,
die man abfragen kann? Ja, du hast recht, dann nehmen wir einfach
das als Inventory. Ja, ja, du hast recht, viel besser.
Inventory-ID für Client-ID und Sensorpräfix. Ja, das Ding hat eine Inventory-Nummer, die
können wir eigentlich verwenden. Dann mache ich einfach die Inventory-Nummer
und davor schreibe ich dann Heiz-Champ. Heiz-Champ underscore Inventory-Number
underscore Sensorname. Ja, das ist eine gute Idee, Chet, das machen
wir. Das ist dann wahrscheinlich Get Inventory
Art oder sowas. Nee, ich glaube, das ist wirklich Get Inventory.
Können wir machen. Ja, das machen wir. Das ist eine gute Idee.
Also, Network Interfaces, get. Ich will trotzdem mal gucken, wie man die Mac-Adresse
rauskriegt. Interfaces, get-all-network-interfaces.
Was kann man sich hier da... Mac? Physical heißt das bestimmt, get-physical-address.
Ja, Moment, aber ich muss erst mal sagen, dass ich bei meinen Interfaces kein Loopback
und sowas haben will. So, type.
Ja, genau, das sieht gut aus. Scheiße, was gibt es denn da alles ab?
All is the end, Alter. Ja, das muss man überprüfen, dass es kein
all is the end ist. Ganz, ganz wichtig.
Und auch kein Slip. Was? Weh mal, was es da alles gibt.
Token Ring, alles klar, natürlich. Very high speed DSL, also was, was wir in Deutschland
wahrscheinlich nie erleben werden. Okay, es reicht, wenn das Ethernet ist.
Genau, hier, where, interface, type, type, Ethernet, geht das vielleicht ein bisschen
lang, sowas da. Ja, nicht mal so übel. Da kann man sich jetzt
die Mac-Adresse ausgeben lassen. Gucken wir doch mal, gucken wir mal, geben
wir mal meine Mac-Adresse aus. Also, wir geben jetzt erst mal Name aus
oder sowas, falls das. Ach nee, ich ja Description Name, okay, mal gucken, was der das ausgibt.
Ah ja, alles klar, ENS 33, Bridge, Bridge, Docker 0.
Okay, doch keine, doch. Okay, wie kriege ich jetzt raus, was mein
Interface ist, was ins Internet geht? Da müsste ich jetzt wahrscheinlich gucken,
ob das ein Gateway oder so gesetzt hat oder ob das Routing-Eintrag hat für sich als
die. Boah, fuck. Gibt es da sowas?
Sowas wie ETH, Route oder Gateway oder sowas? Okay, was gibt es denn da alles zum angucken?
ID, Description, Name, Speed, Primary, gut, nee. Is Receive Only, Get Physical Address
zu String, ja gut, das gibt mir die Mac-Adresse, aber da sagen wir mal nicht, ob das mein Primary
Interface ist. Was haben wir denn hier? Get IP Properties,
kann man dann da alles auslesen, Anycast Address, Gateway Addresses, ja genau, noch schauen wir
mal gut. Okay, hier hat es Microsoft auch ein bisschen übertrieben, oder? Gateway IP Address
Information Collection, na klar. Nimm einfach alle Macs als Seed, das wäre eine typische
Microsoft-Variante für Windows-Aktivierung und dann ändert sich eine Netzwerkkarte und
danach erscheint es als neues Device und es funktioniert nicht mehr. Gateway Address,
okay, ich muss jetzt echt mal kurz gucken, was es da ausgibt. Gateway Address Information,
jetzt übertreibt es halt mal bei Microsoft. Sowas kommt da jetzt raus, ach guck mal, es
gibt nur eine mit einem Gateway, ja dann muss das mal ein Primary sein, nee nicht unbedingt,
aber für meine Verhältnisse sollte das eigentlich reichen. Na das ist zu Java mäßig. Man könnte
noch ein Interface davon machen, dass man es nicht zu sehr koppelt, sowas wie iMutable
Gateway IP Address Information Collection Factory Adapter, das wäre noch besser und
da noch Interface hinten dran, falls einer das i nicht gesehen hat. Das finde ich eine
gute Idee, das sollten wir machen. Also könnte ich doch jetzt eigentlich gucken, if eth
Get IP Properties Gateway Address count größer 0, dann ist das mal ein Primary Interface.
Das ist jetzt übrigens sowas, wo ich einen Kommentar sinnvoll finde, weil keiner, der
das nachher liest und ich in ein, zwei Tagen auch nicht mehr weiß, warum ich das da hingeschrieben
habe. Das ist richtig, es mag nur ein Default Gateway geben können, aber es kann mehrere
Gateways geben. So also bla bla bla, das kommt weg und jetzt da drinnen einfach eth Get
Physical Address und dann mal schauen, ob das jetzt meine Neckadresse ausgibt. Hä, was
ist das für eine kacke Schreibweise. Na gut, es ist ohne Doppelpunkte einfach nur. Expectio,
ne ich nehme die, ich nehme die ID von meiner Heizung, kein Problem. Das ist mir jetzt auch,
während ich das gebastelt habe, bin ich da drauf gekommen, aber ich finde die Idee gut.
Ich wollte bei der Gelegenheit einfach mal gucken, wie man Mac Adressen, was passiert
wenn ich sage, du String, kommt es dann schöner raus? Nee, egal, das passt aber auch, das
ist in Ordnung. Das ist in Ordnung, ja. Jemand, der Tasmota verwendet, wird das ähnlich sehen,
die Tasmota, die Standard Tasmota Einträge sehen so aus. Der nimmt einfach die Mac Adresse,
na gut, das passt doch eigentlich. So. Mac. Und jetzt, wie kriege ich denn den Hostname
raus? Jetzt, das wird ein Wahnsinns. Man könnte ja Hostname nehmen plus Mac. Ist Schwachsinn,
ich muss einfach nur, Hostname, wie kriege ich den Hostname raus? Bestimmt irgendwas mit
DNS. DNS get Hostname. Also DNS get Hostname. Da könnte ich dann sowas hier draus bauen
zum Beispiel. Hostname underscore Mac. Guck mal hier, das ist eigentlich eine ziemlich
gute Idee, oder? Also die, ich meine, die ist, also mehr einzigartig kannst du nicht
sein. Ein Mac reicht, der Hostname, den kann man sich eigentlich sparen an der Stelle,
die ist nicht wirklich, das ist jetzt nicht wirklich notwendig, dass der Host da drin
ist. Aber eigentlich ist das eine ziemlich gute, gute Idee. Find ich nicht schlecht.
Das muss ich mir mal, das muss ich mir mal speichern, das kann man bestimmt mal gebrauchen.
Aber für den Fall nehmen wir wahrscheinlich wirklich die Idee von der Heizung, das erscheint
mir sinnvoller. WTF Mac schon? Ja, seit zweieinhalb Stunden oder so. Gut, jetzt haben wir das ausprobiert,
komplett, komplett random, komplett useless, weil brauchen tun wir es nicht, aber es war
mal gut rauszubekommen, wie es funktioniert. Ok, das JSON zusammenbauen funktioniert auch,
das heißt, das heißt, so die basic Sachen haben wir rausbekommen, wie es funktioniert.
Wie? Ok, jetzt müssen wir das Ganze mal ein bisschen ordentlich machen und mal überlegen,
wie, wie können wir da jetzt irgendwie ordentliche Klassen draus bauen, dass das, dass da was
sinnvolles bei, bei rumkommt. So, ich mach mal kurz ein Git, Git, Git, init, Git, add,
alles rein, Git, commit, a-m, init, so. Ich hab jetzt alles mögliche committed, was ich
überhaupt nicht committen will, aber ich, ich wollte einfach mal, dass ich im Zweifelsfall
nachgucken kann, was ich hier gebastelt hab. Mach mal weg. So, also, das ergibt doch alles
so weit Sinn. Ich überleg grad, wie wir weitermachen. Also wir haben jetzt rausbekommen, wie es funktioniert.
Ich kann den Kram jetzt anlegen. Was machen wir dann jetzt als nächstes? Ich muss den
Schalter, genau, ich brauch nen Schalter, ich brauch nen Schalter, ich muss gucken,
wie ich nen Schalter anlegen kann. Jetzt, jetzt wirds etwas. Ok, wie leg ich nen Schalter
an? Das hier legt ein Binary Sensor an, der an oder aus sein kann. Das ist für die Heizung
ganz sinnvoll, aber ich brauch nen Schalter. Ich brauch keine, ich brauch kein, also ich
brauch nicht nur ein, ich zeig's mal. Ich brauch nicht nur, ob Heizung an oder aus,
ich brauch nen Schalter, wo ich das an und ausschalte. So, also, also, also, das heißt,
wir brauchen jetzt einmal hier den. Das ist doch immer gleich. Wie serialist man damit
eigentlich Klassen? Jasonobject? Gibt's da so was wie Jason serialize oder sowas? Ah
ja, hier, serializer. Testen wir mal was, ob das funktioniert. Serialize a gleich 1,
2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15, 16, 17, 18, 19, 20, 21, 22, 23, 24,
24, 25, 26, 27, 28, 29, 30, 31, 32, 33, 34, 33, 34, 35, 36, 36, 37, 37, 38, 39,
40, 50, 51, 52, 53, 54, 55, 56, 56, 57, 58, 59, 60, 67, 60, 68, 70, 70, 71, 72,Qué?
H drill
können oder kommt dann noch automatisieren ich habe schon alles es geht mir jetzt hauptsächlich
darum also ich habe schon thermostate aber thermostate wohlgeweckt an den heizkörpern
das funktioniert alles auch schon ich will jetzt erst mal alle infos von meiner heizung in meiner
heim automatisierung haben und ich will die möglichkeit haben die heizung auf warmwasser
und heizung oder nur auf warmwasser umzuschalten das geht noch nicht da muss ich jedes mal in
keller was sagt auto vervollständigen ist fast wie cheaten bis bis es dich mal jebaitet es
gibt ein paar auto vervollständigen und refactor hinweise in rider die ich bisschen fragwürdig
finde zum beispiel möchte der wenn du essen wollt schreibst immer dass du eine lokale
metode verwendest anstatt essen wollt zu schreiben und sowas das finde ich unsinnig aber das meiste
ist schon sinnvoll nicht in keller pepo fett so sieht es aus warum soll ich unnötiger weise in
keller gehen wenn ich das von hier oben schalten kann ok jetzt jetzt gucken wir mal wie wir da
ein ein switch anlegen würden also wir brauchen ein was brauchen wir denn für ein switch dass wir
können das alles sondern wir brauchen bloß noch ein command topic ein command topic und wir
müssen alles durch switch ersetzen switch switch state topic switch und wir brauchen noch ein
command topic das set heißt ein command command topic und dann muss man noch bestimmt noch
irgendwie angeben die weiß type switch ne wobei das weiß der anhand dessen hier ok
war es das jetzt schon das wäre jetzt easy das ist switch der heißt jetzt genauso wie der andere
das ist natürlich ziemlich bescheuert aber das ist switch so und jetzt kann ich nämlich also
ich meine der hat absolut keine funktion der schalter jetzt außer da zu sein aber jetzt kann
ich zum beispiel auch hierhin gehen sagt edit jetzt waren wir mal neu also das ist beide
nicht mein echter hau was ist denn das ist eine testinstallation jetzt für den stream ja
title neu neuen titel eiken haben die haben die schönes haben die schönes eiken für keller
material design eikens muss mal gucken ob die ob die was für für keller haben diese seite
die ist immer so langs aber ich habe das schon längst reingeklickt irgendwie floor oder sowas
vielleicht ah guck mal 0123 floor a floor b floor negativ worden jawoll das brauche
eiken flut nee was ist das prefix nochmal dafür md md genau ich glaube mal ich glaube
man durfte auch hr machen mittlerweile so save guck mal so ein knopf für den keller
bärm so add card button ja genau so darm darme heizung switch show name show state show eiken
tap action hold action toggle das will ich will ich dass es einfach dass es einfach beim antippen
schaltet wir können noch eine konfirm action machen weil das will ich wirklich nur nach so
kommt man jetzt könnte ich die heizung an und ausschalten zack glaube ich habe nicht das
richtige genommen doch habe ich also das steht das hat noch überhaupt null funktion das ist
einfach nur jetzt knopf angelegt zum heizung schalten also man sieht ja dass es nicht funktioniert
ja guck das schickt die ganze zeit das schickt die ganze zeit jetzt hier messages on messages
off und es bestätigt keiner was aber von der idee her so soll so soll es dann sein wir müssen jetzt
noch einbauen dass der konfirmend dass der konfirmend soll wir sagen jetzt jedoch keine
aktion default action code editor wie ging das noch mal konfirm action und firm true war das so
ist das mozilla web web things nein das ist homosystem action homosystem gab es ein extra
tap action konfirm konfirmation action toggle tap action ok ok jetzt weiß ich wie ich es machen
muss also tap action und dann tru tru lul weh action alter lass mich hier drauf klicken
ich hasse solche seiten mitdenken ok ich schreibe das wort action einfach von hand so default
toggle also toggle toggle ja toggle so und jetzt sollte der mich fragen ob ich schalten
will beim are you sure want to toggle toggle jawoll gut weil für heizung an und ausschalten
will ich auf jeden fall irgendeine sinnvolle rückfrage haben schalte ich noch fünf mal am
tag aus versehen weil ich da drauf klicke die heizung an und aus so ist die seite höchst höchst
sus ganz schön sus das ist auch nicht mehr angesagt oder glaubt das ist nicht mehr so
nicht mehr so dabei jetzt das ist ja vollkommen rip quatsch quatsch mit sus das ist ja moment
mal das muss man muss man mal sortieren view a high das ist ja vollkommen rib na gut ich
kann es insofern verstehen das macht das kann man ein zwei monate spielen aber danach ist
ja irgendwann auch mal die luft raus ok so meine heizung an und aus wunderbar natürlich
funktioniert das ganze nicht und jetzt jetzt kommt ja jetzt komplett jetzt jetzt kommt
ja das komplizierte erst mal ich muss das irgendwie verbinden miteinander ja sechs
wochen twitch meta kommt auch ungefähr hin würde ich sagen also es war also man muss
sagen fall guys into among us meta war das ja auf twitch das ging so über erst mal haben
die leute zwei monate fall guys gespielt und dann sind die quasi so rüber rüber geslided
zu among us was ist denn jetzt aktuelles twitch meta gerade außer halb naggisch auf der banane
rumrutschen final fantasy 14 stimmt was was auch lustig ist das habe ich im friseur schon
gespielt da war das noch richtig ja nicht so angesagt und jetzt haben wir keinen bock
und jetzt ist es voll twitch meta gta rp das stimmt aber das ist das gibt es auch schon
länger ich muss ja persönlich sagen ich finde gta rp nicht wirklich spannend also ich kann
es verstehen warum es die leute gucken das kann ich bei vielen sachen überhaupt nicht
nachvollziehen aber gta rp kann ich nachvollziehen aber mich persönlich interessiert nicht wenn
ich gta rp haben will dann gehe ich einfach frankfurter hauptbahnhof das ist real life
gta rp aber gut das ist natürlich kein argument das war jetzt eher ein witz weil ich sehe
es ja selbst so es natürlich bescheuert warum sollte man in real life straftaten begehen
das macht vielleicht kurzzeitig spaß machen aber bestimmt nicht so viel und nicht so
lange wie gta online in frankfurt außerdem wirst du in frankfurt abgestochen wenn du
es probierst genau dann lieber gta rp ne also ich kann schon verstehen warum die leute gta
rp gucken aber ich finde es nicht sondern nicht spannend
mach serverless trigger function bei azure und buche die zeitbar self learning in azure
ab ja valorant ist dauermeter geworden das stimmt aber war weitem nicht so krass wie
es am anfang mit den drops war ja ich ich dachte valorant muss ich muss ich ehrlich
sagen ich dachte also ich dachte nicht dass es floppt so wirklich also ich dachte schon
dass das uns erhalten bleibt ich meine da ist riot dahinter aber ich dachte nicht dass
das permanent so ein riesen ding ist ja ok probieren wir mal probieren wir mal weiter
also wir haben jetzt einen schalter bin ich schon mal bin ich schon mal happy so was jetzt
natürlich noch ein bisschen was jetzt der nächste punkt ist ich muss mitbekommen wenn
ich auf den schalter klicke weil ihr seht ja es passiert ja noch gar nichts das bedeutet
ich muss jetzt nicht nur das müssen wir übrigens eh alles mal in irgendwelche halbwegs sinnvollen
klassen basteln das ist ja hier untereinander geschrieben wie das könnte fast schon perl
sein was der binary sensor muss es gibt keinen binary sensor mehr den habe ich hier raus
gekickt brauche ich auch nicht wozu brauche ich ein binary sensor wenn ich den switch
habe der ist einfach nur drinne weil ich den schon mal announced hab aktuell habe ich
den ich hab den rausgeschmissen den binary sensor moin del trion so also weiter ihr müssen
jetzt drauf hören wenn einer im web interface auf den knopf drückt wie machen wir das denn
am besten ich muss das topic subscriben wie geht das bin ich jetzt wirklich ein bisschen
überfragt wie wir gehen das wir machen mal hier sowas hier publik publik wollte sub string
topic das wird so nicht funktionieren ich bin mir aber gar nicht ich weiß überhaupt
nicht wie das funktioniert hier sub subscribesync ich muss das topic subscriben ja was wie soll
ich den satz denn auf deutsch sagen ja ich muss da ich muss das ich muss das thema abonnieren
ich muss das thema abonnieren klingt auch nicht besser ich muss das thema subscribieren
get thema subscrib subscription ich habe hier ein emote was super ist in kombi mit allen
pepe emotes zeigt mal her der chain law kennt sich was emotes ein das ist tatsächlich gut
das adde ich gleich mal das habe ich schon ein paar mal gesehen das ist wirklich ganz
cool das kannst du im prinzip mit allen emotes zusammen verwenden was du hattest vorhin schön
das beispiel gelöscht wirklich stimmt ich habe es vorhin gelöscht tatsächlich ok wir
gucken jetzt erstmal an wie das funktioniert also sub wobei wir gucken einfach bei denen
auf der auf der shit hub seite alles zu hier alles weg hier manage klein da waren die examples
subscribesync so subscribesync mqt topic filter bilder also die typen die diese library programmiert
haben die stehen unglaublich auf irgendwelche bilder jetzt mal jetzt mal ernsthaft warum
nicht so warum nicht so ich mein was ist der vorteil von diesem ding zu dem hier moment
das geht auch ok ich habe nichts gesagt es ergibt tatsächlich sinn das ergibt tatsächlich
sinn man kann das topic direkt angeben oder wenn man mehr options braucht dann nimmt man
das ok ich habe nichts gesagt es macht sinn zu früh zu früh zu früh geflamed passt tatsächlich
ok topic es ist in ordnung ist in ordnung so wie kriege ich denn jetzt überhaupt mit
ob das was also ob das subscribt hat also es muss hier ein event oder in den callback oder
sowas geben ich mein subscribesync schön und gut aber das kommt da als antwort b ich muss
ja irgendwie den callback oder sowas kriegen wenn ich subscribt habe moment da brauche ich
einen example dafür ok da wo es interessant wird hört natürlich die hilfeseite auf subscribesync
braucht er irgendein example für es mqtt klein subscription manager was
zu den ok subscribesync topik test application message received handler
ach du große scheiße was ist das denn application message received handler
ist das ist das ein event ist das ein callback den ich angeben muss oder
monka was was für eine ausgeburt des bösen gibt das denn hier wenn es fertig ist
was ok das darf ich auf jeden fall hier schon mal nicht im subscriben das muss ich hier
oben machen ach du kacke ok das war jetzt mal hier also wir testen es einfach also subscribesync
message gibt es da sowas wie topic oder application message wisst ihr warum wisst ihr warum das
so kompliziert ist ich gehe davon aus die die library programmiert haben haben das erst
mal ursprünglich so klassisch event basiert callback mäßig gebaut und haben es mit der
zeit umgebaut in essen awaits kompatibel und da kommt dann so komische dinge bei raus
ich hatte im studium leute die so ihre java metoden benannt haben es gibt schlimmeres
ich meine du kannst dir wenigstens was darunter vorstellen was ich was ich persönlich jetzt
natürlich ganz sinnvoll finden würde wenn es nicht application message received händler
heißen würde sondern zu keine ahnung subscription message received oder sowas irgendwas wo man
sich was drunter vorstellen kann weil wer kommt denn auf sowas applique application
message so application message topic payload payload convert payload to string wunderbar
ok jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ob das funktioniert ich muss mal kurz who's the man machen so
also mqtt client subscribe await ich bin froh dass ich das gerebt habe das kann man wenigstens
halbwegs verwenden topic alles ich will alles angezeigt bekommen so von der idee her wenn
ich jetzt was publish sollte ich das eigentlich angezeigt bekommen kann ich mal irgendwas
publishen irgendwas was irgendwas kleines nichts damit zu tun hat hier ja leck leck 3d funktioniert
kleck 3d easy kleck 3d dass das funktioniert es ist aber ganz schön soll ich sagen umständlich
gemacht kleck 3d also wenn man weiß wie es funktioniert ist das nice das blöde dabei
ist jetzt nur dass das global ist das heißt wie dispatch ich jetzt das von hier in irgendeiner
art und weise hier ich will das ja hier subscriben und dann hier krieg ich ein event ich weiß
was ich mache leute big brain library reactive x reactive jetzt wird jetzt wird es jetzt wird
es richtet uns system reactive jawohl so jetzt passt mal auf ich hab ich hab die idee willst
du mal talk was achso ne ne passt schon ich habe nur verstanden das willst du mal talk
ne ne ne brauch ich nicht krieg ich schon krieg ich schon hin falls du der library maintainer
bist schön dass du so ein library gemacht hast auch wenn ich ein bisschen am flamen
bin gelses also macht ihr macht ihr dann nix also wir machen das jetzt alles ich hab ich
hab ich hab die ich hab ich hab die idee das mal auf massive massive big brain idee wenn
man subscribt kriegt man ein eye observable ein eye observable swing einfach nur payload
zurück so alles klar muss nur gucken wie krieg ich das da rein
hoffe du postest den code auf github ja das muss ich mal gucken warum geht das nicht was
ist das für schmerzen achso ja ja passt schon das fix sich gleich fix sich gleich von
alleine ich muss ja was zurückgeben sonst klappt das ganze nicht so ich hab ich hab
ich hab die idee leute also wir subscriben jetzt wir subscriben jetzt und jetzt ich weiß
nicht wie ich das jetzt mache am besten die idee finde ich sinnvoll also wenn ich subscribe
kriege ich hier einen stream von messages zurück das ist das ist schon mal besser besser
als hier ja du hast recht das muss ein task sein was aber blödsinn ich muss es noch nicht
mal essen machen ok wie kriege ich die messages von hier da rein das mal kurz in mich gehen
man konnte doch so einen so einen standard ist so so so so so ein receiver sender ding
warte mal ich hab eine idee wie man das machen private read only irgendwie subject oder so
hieß das string so guck ob das funktioniert ob das schön ist weiß ich nicht aber funktionieren
könnte das ganze so und jetzt subscrib topic und hier oben sagen wir jetzt next war das
glaube ich next so args application message payload convert ne string ne wat wie war das
noch mal nicht payload payload convert payload to string sowas was kann reactive extensions
da besser als einfach ein channel also man könnte das wahrscheinlich auch mit dem channel
machen reactive reactive integer ein channel wäre wahrscheinlich noch viel sinnvoller
ja du hast komplett recht ja ja eigentlich eigentlich ist bescheuert hier ja das könnte
man auch mit dem channel machen so subscrib das ist das ist eine message queue jetzt gucken
ob das jetzt funktioniert was ich mir da überlegt habe return subject so und jetzt und jetzt
mal gucken ob das geht jetzt muss ich nicht erwarten ok subscrib ist vielleicht ein bisschen
dumm aber von der idee her sollte es jetzt schon mal funktionieren message cw message
so hups run geht geht ok das ist doch schon mal viel schöner als dieser komische standardmäßige
application message bla sonst was wenn mich stört es ein bisschen dass es subscrib ist
aber ich mein besser als die ursprüngliche variante ist es auf jeden fall so wie kann
man das jetzt noch ein bisschen verschönerisieren ja irgendjemand hat geschrieben wir könnten
einfach einen channel nehmen das finde ich tatsächlich sogar ganz sinnvoll warum machen
wir irgendwie so observable zeug jetzt musst du nur noch auf topic filtern stimmt das ist
richtig ich muss auf topic filtern stimmt ich muss auf topic filtern dann bleibe ich
doch bei einem observable weil das kann ich filtern nur dann ist sogar dann ist so wahrscheinlich
sogar noch besser mensch mensch das ist jetzt an string ok dann machen wir oben kein string
sondern application message draus was mqtt application message oder konverten wir es
nicht dahin sondern application message und jetzt filtern wir und sagen wer message topic
gleich topic select message payload string bamm huge guck mal hier fack jetzt haben wir
hier mal hoch ich darf das nicht ja weil tru du du sleep eins dann nicht wegen dem topic
funktioniert das nicht ich glaube ich weiß warum das nicht funktioniert das mit dem topic
raute wird wahrscheinlich so nicht so nicht funktionieren wir machen wir machen ein richtiges
wir machen ein richtiges topic topic l topic l ist es in dem fall hier ok topic l da ist
es kleck 3d einmal in der sekunde funktioniert huge wir haben einen ordentlichen mqtt klein
der man bedienen kann sehr gut ohne ohne ohne 25.000 bilder bilder in bilder geschachtelt
wie ist der emoji support das eine gute frage wenn man nicht sicher ob rider emojis kann
das probieren gleich mal aus alle wichtigsten ja kann gut easy dann dann ist gut dann kann
ich es weiterverwenden ok kleck 3d wunderbar ok ich kann mqtt sachen publishen und ich
kann mqtt sachen subscriben also emojis in topics das müsste wahrscheinlich auch funktionieren
ich denke das funktioniert das ist ganz normales unicode zeug ich denke das geht funktioniert
emoji topic ich wette mit dir sachen die in c++ programmiert
wären da hätte das nicht funktioniert weil der standard string in c++ ist halt was unicode
support angeht nicht existent der hat der hat schlicht und ergreifend keinerlei unicode
oder keinerlei encoding support man kann ja gar nicht sagen unicode das stimmt ja gar
nicht so genau unicode sind ja plus die die die die die vorgeben welche also welche zeichen
aufgenommen werden an welchen positionen und das eigentliche encoding ist ja dann das
Wichtige, also UTF-8, 16 oder 32.
Windows ist UTF-16, ja, Windows ist UTF-16 und.NET ist intern auch UTF-16, wohingegen
Rust komplett intern UTF-8 ist.
Das hat aber bei.NET historische Gründe, soweit ich weiß.
Die haben damals schon, bevor es das als Standard gab, sich dafür entschieden, das in 2-Byte-Zeichen
zu machen.
Was eigentlich wirklich das Schlechte aus allen Welten ist, ja, also UTF-16 ist richtig
hängen geblieben.
So nach dem Motto, du hast immer 2-Byte, aber du kannst trotzdem 4-Byte-Zeichen nicht
gescheit reinpacken.
Es ist Mist.
Also UTF-8 ist das einzig Sinnvolle, finde ich.
UTF-8 ist einmal ASCII-kompatibel und das nächste ist, du musst eh gucken, ob es ein
Fleck gibt für das nächste Zeichen.
Doch UTF-8 reicht für alles aus, klar.
UTF-8 ist, finde ich, auch das einzig Sinnvolle.
Man könnte noch sagen, UTF-32 ist irgendwie sinnvoll, weil du quasi immer feste Zeichen
hast und quasi alles, was es gibt aktuell, ich glaube mehr als 4-Byte gibt es nicht,
bekommst du irgendwie rein.
Also ich finde UTF-8 ist das einzig Sinnige, wird ja auch quasi nahezu für alles mittlerweile
verwendet, solange es nicht eine Website aus Frontpage ist.
Gibt es das eigentlich noch?
Aktuelle Version von 2003, na okay.
Es gibt Sachen, denen weide ich nicht nach.
Also ich bin ja für UTF-69, wie auch immer das aussehen soll, weil eigentlich muss es
ja immer was hoch 2, also Zweierpotenz sein, aber da kann man mal.
Ist 420 eine Zweierpotenz?
Eher nicht, oder?
Frontpage kann bestimmt schon Angular und Vue.
Na ja, Frontpage kann ja im Prinzip Syntax-Highlighting für HTML und JavaScript.
Du kannst in Frontpage bestimmt Vue basteln, aber das wird Syntax-Highlighting komplett
versagen, weil das nicht mit neuem JavaScript Zeug zurechtkommt.
Yep, okay, also, lass mal kurz überlegen.
Was haben wir denn jetzt hingekriegt, also wir haben einen MQTT Client, der funktioniert.
Damit bin ich schon mal wirklich sehr zufrieden, das gefällt mir, wobei ich diese Syntax hier
nicht so wirklich schön finde, na, subscribesubscribe, das ist schon ein bisschen, ein bisschen Paynes-Champ-ig,
aber, gibt es bei 20.000 Twitch-Follower Fußleak?
Hab ich mir noch keine Gedanken drüber gemacht, aber es wird wahrscheinlich weder bei 20.000
noch bei 30.000 noch bei 100.000 Fußleak geben, zumal ich meinen Fuß sogar schon öfters
geleakt habe, ich hab Fotos mit der Katz, da ist mein Fuß drauf, also wenn du meine Füße
sehen willst, Chainlaw, das, ich mein, ich könnte, also wenn du subscriben willst, kann
ich auch ein OnlyFans machen, ja, ne, aber wenn du sehen willst, kannst du auf Twitter
gucken, da gibt es das bestimmt irgendwo, ja, nackter Fuß, ne, ich glaub nackten Fuß
hab ich noch nicht geleakt.
Wie sind eigentlich die OnlyFans Pläne, was Porn angeht, ich hab gehört, die haben jetzt
zurückgerudert, die haben ja erst gesagt, sie wollen keine Sachen mehr promoten und
anbieten und dann haben die gesagt, fuck, dann ist ja nix mehr von uns übrig und das
haben sie es sein gelassen, jetzt geht das ganz normal weiter.
Okay, also, wie können wir das hier, können wir das vielleicht noch ein bisschen verschönern,
ich mein, Sub, Sub, Subscribe, ich hab ne Idee, wir können das weniger hässlich machen,
wir sagen hier einfach Refactor, Rename, wir nennen das einfach Filter und dann Subscribe,
ich mein, ich könnte das auch MQTT Klein Filter Message Builder nennen, dann sind wir
ein bisschen näher dran am Original, aber so ist das doch wirklich ganz nice, ich finde
das wirklich recht schick, du sagst MQTT Klein Filter, dann sagst du Topic, also in dem Fall,
wir müssen jetzt natürlich auch mal erstmal gucken, ob das funktioniert, was ich hier
gebaut hab, Topic, Command, Topic, Set, Message, so und von der Idee her sollte da jetzt kommen
on, off, wenn ich den Schalter drücke im Web Interface, probieren wir das mal, zack, zack,
zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, funktioniert nicht, ah, lull, Ausrufezeichen wieder vergessen,
so nochmal, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, bäm, on, off, on, off, also, ja nice,
man kriegt das mit, gut, jetzt bekomm ich mit, wenn einer den Schalter im Web Interface
gedrückt hat, jetzt ist die nächste Frage, wie sag ich dem denn jetzt, also ihr seht
ja, wenn ich den Schalter drücke und dann keine Bestätigung kommt, dann geht er wieder
aus, ich muss jetzt eine Message schicken, wahrscheinlich an State, ja genau, ich muss
an State Topic jetzt zurückschicken, ist aktiviert, ok, das probieren wir jetzt mal aus, also,
Await, wir das Essunck machen, Await, MQTT klein, Publish wollen wir jetzt, Publishen
und zwar wollen wir jetzt auf das State, das müssen wir unbedingt Kapseln in paar, in
paar, wie auch immer wir das zusammenbauen, aber nicht so, so ist es wirklich abartig,
was hat der jetzt für Schmerzen, ah jetzt geht es ok, Message muss dann sein, in dem
Fall, naja wir schalten es jetzt an, wir machen jetzt einmal Hardcoded on da rein, so, schauen
wir mal, also da sollte es sich jetzt einschalten und dann angeschaltet bleiben, on, und, und,
und dann bleibt eingeschaltet, nice, hier kann man jetzt auch nachgucken, was der für
Most hier, Most Reasons Receive Messages on, ok, sehr schön, sehr gut, gut wir können
die Message im Prinzip hier reinschreiben, dann schaltet er an und aus, off, off, on,
ah es funktioniert, guckt, so und jetzt sollte der Knopf auch hier funktionieren, Bäm, der
Button, es tut, es schaltet zwar noch nicht die Heizung, aber es funktioniert im Webinterface
schon mal, an, aus, wunderbar, es hat ja vorhin noch nicht funktioniert, vorhin habe ich
drauf geklickt und es ist einfach gar nichts passiert, zack, und zack, ja sehr schön,
sehr gut, sehr gut, das gefällt mir, ja gut, ich muss sagen das finde ich jetzt schon mal
ganz gut, das finde ich schon mal nice, das finde ich schon mal nice, so jetzt ist natürlich
die nächste Sache, wir müssen das irgendwie mit der Heizung integrieren, das finde ich
aber cool, dass das jetzt schon mal funktioniert, dass das Home Assistant MQTT Zeug klappt,
da bin ich schon mal beruhigt, dass das an sich geht, was gibt es eigentlich im Video
oder ist das über deinen Werbe, habe ich schon gemacht, achso, ja doch, ach nee, das stimmt,
das habe ich nicht, das stimmt, das habe ich noch nicht gemacht, ich habe mehrere Videos
dazu gemacht, was ich jetzt aktuell mache und so drum herum, aber Werdegang ist eigentlich
eine gute Idee, das schreibe ich hier mal auf, ja das könnte ich machen, das ist eine
gute Idee, ich weiß ich habe es hier im Stream ja schon öfters erzählt, aber das ist eine
gute Idee, das habe ich glaube ich noch nie in einem Video gepackt, also das einzige Video
was ich dazu gemacht habe, wo ich mich ausführlich darüber ausgelassen habe ist, hier das mache
ich auf der Arbeit von 2019, also hier bei mir auf YouTube und ich habe mit dem Noel
mal ein Video darüber gemacht, allgemein zur Fachinformatik Ausbildung, wer das noch
nicht gesehen hat, kann sich das auch angucken, da haben wir uns 20 Minuten über Dinge ausgelassen,
es ist eigentlich echt ein gutes Video geworden, digitaloceancode.com, hä, was ist das für
eine komische Scam Seite, das ist doch irgendeine Scam Seite, das kann mir doch keiner erzählen,
warum sind irgendwelche Antworten, Linux haut, das muss ich mir mal in meiner Linux VM angucken,
das mache ich nicht unter Windows auf, private, ich mache das mal klein, nicht dass da jetzt
gleich irgendeine Porn Seite kommt oder so, immer zu, hallo, das ist nicht das, was ich
haben will, Porn-Ed Verlinkung, ja, das ist, was so, das ist irgendeine Werbe Seite, die
mein Video gerippt hat, okay, was auch immer, man weiß es nicht, SOS, aber richtig SOS,
Strike DSG4, ja wir gucken mal wo die sitzen, Moment, Moment, wie hieß die Seite jetzt
nochmal, wisst ihr, ich habe jetzt schon zugemacht, digitaloceancode.com, Alter, who is, who is,
who is, oh nein, die sind beim gleichen Domain Registrar wie ich, da weißt du schonmal, wer
bei dem ist, das sind irgendwelche, ich bin ja auch nur bei denen, weil die keinerlei Anschriften
kontrollieren, weil ich keinen Bock habe an Ausweis und Sachen hinzuschicken, weil die
keinerlei Anschriften, und billig sind, okay, man bekommt es nicht raus, also, mit welchem
Programm läuft deine Linux, mit welches Linux hast du, das ist vor allem bei Workstation
und die habe ich einfach auf dem zweiten Desktop von Windows, deswegen kann ich auch so schnell
zwischen Windows und Linux hin und her schalten, und das ist, genau wie der Bot das schreibt,
das ist ein Manjaro Linux mit E3WM, excellent Mod, ja, big brain Mod, arch by the way Leute,
so, also, machen wir mal weiter, wo sind wir stehen geblieben, also, wir können jetzt,
wir können jetzt Sachen, Sachen in Home Assistant anlegen, und wir können Sachen schalten,
und wir bekommen mit, wenn sie einer schaltet, das ist doch schon mal gut, das ist auch schon
mal so die Basics für alles, was wir sonst brauchen, jetzt muss ich mir mal überlegen,
wie könnte man das denn gescheit irgendwie in ein paar Klassen packen, weil ich meine,
ich will jetzt ja wohl kaum für jeden Eintrag so ein Ding hier machen, das erste, was ich
mal ausprobieren will, ist das hier, also, dieses, dies ist ein Eintrag hier für Device,
das ist das, was man hier sieht, bei Device Info, also sprich, das hier, also, das da,
Device Name, Hersteller, Modell und sonst was, das ist ja bei allen Sensoren, die ich
hier anlege, gleich, deswegen ist die Frage, könnten wir das nicht, könnten wir da nicht
irgendwie eine eigene Klasse draus machen, die das dann ordentlich serialized, also quasi
sowas wie hier Public, Glass, tja, wie nennt sich denn sowas hier, Device Info, ich werde
da mal, warte mal, ich werde da mal noch was ordentliches reinschreiben, was es dann da
auftaucht, also, was gab es denn da alles, was gab es denn da alles zur Auswahl, ähm,
mit Curl hatten wir das aus, nee, irgendwas mit Garagentor hatten wir doch da, hier, also,
was gab es denn da alles, Identifier Name, Modell gibt es noch, Modell, Manufacturer,
HA, MQTT, mal gucken, was es da alles zur Auswahl gibt, Modell, also, Identifiers haben
wir, Manufacturer, Modell, Name, Software Version, ok, also, Manufacturer, der Twitch Chat, was
sonst, ohne Twitch Chat hat das natürlich nicht funktioniert, Q Chat, beste, Edgar
immer noch besser als Piehole, ähm, ich sehe schon ein paar Versionen her, wie kommt die
da jetzt überhaupt drauf, ich hab mir das vor, fragt mich nicht vor einem Jahr oder
so mal angeguckt, achso, das war jetzt dabei, dass jemand im Chat das Spot-Kommando, oder
vor einem halben Jahr, ja, also ich muss sagen, rein von der Usability her, hat mir das deutlich
besser gefallen als Piehole, ja, wie das jetzt aktuell ist, weiß ich wirklich nicht, also,
Manufacturer, der Chat, ähm, Modell, was, warum, warum macht man sowas, dass man das
nicht anklicken kann, das ist doch einfach nur hängen geblieben, warum, warum baut man
sowas, ok, Modell, äh, ist, tja, äh, keine Ahnung, Raspberry Pi 4, ich schreibt jetzt
einfach mal irgendwas rein, so, und Software Version hatten wir noch, Software Version
ist natürlich eindeutig, 0.0.0.0.0.1, so, sehr schön, äh, Run, so, mal gucken, ob der
das jetzt da einträgt im Webinterface, guck mal, hat funktioniert, hier, zack, jawoll,
nice, also Device Info nennt man das Ganze anscheinend, da machen wir jetzt nämlich
mal eine eigene Klasse für diese Device Info-Geschichte, weil, egal welchen Sensor ich anlege, ob ich
jetzt einen Binary-Sensor anlegen, einen Schalter anlegen, einen Sensor anlegen, äh, irgendwas,
alles, was ich hier an Geräten anlege, für die Heizung, ist ja, bekommt immer diese Infos,
also dann probieren wir mal, ob wir da eine eigene Klasse für machen können, Public Class,
das nennen wir einfach dann, äh, keine Ahnung, HA, Device Info oder so, HA, Device Info,
warum geht das jetzt nicht, ah, das geht nicht in der, in so, das muss man unten drunter
machen, ne, das ist, das ist natürlich doof, das ist natürlich doof, ne, wäre jetzt praktischer
gewesen, man könnte das hier oben anlegen, also, was, was haben wir denn hier einmal,
Identifiers Name Manufacturer, also fangen wir an, Manufakturer ist, hallo, String, Manufakturer,
Next, String, Name, Next, String, was haben wir sonst noch, Model, String, äh, Version,
so, äh, Identifier haben wir noch, Identifier, eigentlich reicht doch, guck mal, das ist
zwar ein, das ist zwar ein Array von Identifier, aber mal ganz im Ernst, eigentlich reicht
doch eine, oder, ich werde da nie im Leben mehr als ein Identifier angeben, das String
Identifier, so, und können wir das jetzt, das ist jetzt die Frage, wenn ich jetzt dieses
Objekt hier oben einmalig anlege, nennen wir es mal irgendwie keine Route Device oder sowas,
New HA Device Info, wenn ich das jetzt einmalig anlege, Manufakturer, Cute Chat, den kann
man nochmal schreiben, äh, Model, Hobbypaste wird, Sack, Who's Jam, Alter, geht los hier,
ich hab das schon seit ein paar Tagen, ich mach nachher mal Corona Test, ich bin aber
doppelt geimpft, seit ein paar Wochen schon, ich kann eigentlich kein Corona haben, ich
weiß, jetzt kommen die Leute wieder sagen, doch, doch, Max, trotz Impfung kannst du auch
Corona kriegen, ich weiß, aber die Chancen sind deutlich, sind ziemlich gering, und ich
wäre doch nicht gerade in der einen, in dem einen Tag, letzte Woche oder so, wo ich in
Frankfurt war, wenn ich mir noch nicht gerade Corona eingefangen habe, das dann auch noch
trotz Impfung ausbricht, das glaube ich nicht, außerdem würde es mir da wahrscheinlich
deutlich schlechter gehen, wenn ich Corona hätte, hatte jemand von euch Corona, oder
seid ihr alle verschont geblieben, Manufakturer, Cute Chat, das ist Arbeitsallergie, muss doch
heute gar nicht arbeiten, Heizchamp, und als nächstes haben wir noch Version, Moment,
Identifier, Cute Chat ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn, Identifier muss Heizchamp sein, Version
war hier das da, gut, so, und jetzt ist natürlich die große Preisfrage, kann man das jetzt
anstatt dem Kram da reinschreiben, nee, du könntest auch, nee, kann ich, wahrscheinlich
nicht, das könnte ich machen, wenn ich Newtonsoft.json.net nehmen würde, aber das hier ist die neue.net.json
Implementierung, keine Ahnung, ob der das kann, nee, toString funktioniert nicht, toString
wäre einfach nur, das ist Painschamp, ja, ich wollte es mal ausprobieren, ich dachte,
hey, steht.net 6 im Titel, wir müssen noch ein bisschen.net 6 machen, ich hatte Newtonsoft.net
schon installiert, und da habe ich mir gedacht, Moment, ich habe noch letztens fast drüber
gelesen, dass man das jetzt mit.net 6 viel besser machen kann, als noch mit.net 5,
bei.net 5 war das ja auch alles read-only und sowas, den implizierten cast of JSON-Object,
ich glaube nicht, dass das funktioniert, kann man, okay, JSON, aber Serializer ist eigentlich
das Falsche, weil da kriege ich einen String raus, ich will ja keinen String rauskriegen,
ich will ja, dass der das hier für mich serialized, das wird doch so nicht funktionieren, das
klappt nicht, Leute, das klappt nicht, ich gucke mal, was der da draus macht, aber das
wird nicht funktionieren, new JSON-Object, das ist eine gute Idee, das probiere ich danach
mal aus, aber guckt mal hier, das wird nicht, wir machen mal kurz, watch run, nee, nee,
das klappt nicht, das ist eine gute Idee, new JSON, nee, nicht JSON-Object, JSON-Object,
man kann da reinschieben, nee, man kann da bloß G-Value per sonst wie, das funktioniert
nicht, ja, mit Newtonsoft JSON würde das funktionieren, da würde das allein schon funktionieren,
weil du es als Dynamic könntest du das sogar machen dort, wie geht das jetzt, ich habe
keine Ahnung, vielleicht steht das in der Hilfe-Seite drinne, oder was heißt Hilfe-Seite
in diesem komischen Zerfolge,.NET 6 JSON, du meinst, ob das was hat zum, ah, was, äh,
glaube ich nicht, AskValue, das ist System Text JSON, ja, das ist System Text JSON, aber
die.NET 6 Variante, die angeblich, sagt Microsoft, habe ich letztens in einem Talk gehört, die
genauso komfortabel zu verwenden sein soll wie Newtonsoft.NET, erst serialisieren, dann
passen, wie könnte das jetzt funktionieren, ich habe wirklich keine Ahnung, ey, warte
mal, wir machen das mal anders, wir speichern das mal und jetzt vielleicht können wir das
irgendwie so, warte mal, Dynamic, lull, geht das, das wird nicht funktionieren, das kann
nicht sein, das weiß ich nicht, ey, du kannst das mal ausprobieren, ok, wie könnte das,
wie könnte das funktionieren, vielleicht versteht ihr irgendwas, GIFs oder was, was
haben sie hier gemacht, tatsächlich ein GIF, ein GIF und dann nicht mehr animiert, JSON
Node Pass, ja, das, das weiß ich, dass das funktioniert, aber das wollen wir ja nicht,
wir wollen ja das miteinander verbinden, was, übrigens,.NET 6 hat einen Bug, das haben
wir das letzte Mal schon gehabt, der endlos reloaded bei einem Watch, deswegen habe ich
kein Watch genommen, ist aber bald ist Release, ich glaube, es dauert noch einen Monat oder
so, ja, ok, zwei Monate, zwei Monate dauert es noch, mal gespannt, ob sie bis dahin alles
gefixt haben, was es so zu fixen gibt, so, geht das irgendwie, was ich mir hier vorstelle,
sonst installiere ich doch NewtonsoftJSON.NET und dann ist gut, mach einen Builder, der das
JSON Object returnt, ja, meinetwegen, aber wie, wie, wie, wie würde ich das überhaupt
zusammenbauen, mir fällt ja noch nicht mal ein, wie ich das jetzt von Hand zusammenbauen
würde, heute ist iOS 15 Release, mal kurz weitergucken, JSON Object to JSON String, was ist denn das,
was ist da der Unterschied, to JSON String, hä, was ist der Unterschied, ah, es, es wird
nicht Pretty Printed, ok, normales to String formatiert es schön, to JSON String gibt es
einfach aus, ohne irgendwelche hübsche Formatierungsgeschehen, das ist eigentlich auch ganz sinnvoll, kann man
nix sagen, aber erklärt immer noch nicht, wie das funktioniert, würde denn, würde denn
sowas funktionieren, Moment, würde denn, würde denn sowas funktionieren, CheckW gleich new,
ne, ne, funktioniert auch nicht, ne, das funktioniert, also das funktioniert, ich glaube, das geht
nicht, ich glaube, das, ich glaube, das funktioniert nicht, aber wie, wie, wie würde, wie würde
ich denn jetzt hier was, hier was hinzufügen, das ergibt eigentlich keinen Sinn, right to
object ist, ich würde halt für das Hauptobjekt eine Klasse bauen, einfach serialisieren,
ja aber ich muss es doch irgendwie zusammenbauen, und das serialisieren aus dem Hauptobjekt
wird ja nicht funktionieren, weil meine, mein Sensor steckt ja da nicht irgendwie drinne,
es muss doch möglich sein, das zusammenzufügen, das zusammenzubauen irgendwie, add, okay,
man kann hier nicht irgendwas hinzufügen, aber wenn schon, warum gibt es nicht add,
add value, ah, chasen value vielleicht, okay, das, das würde, würde, das würde vielleicht
sogar noch Sinn angeben, device, device gleich new chasen value, ne, nein, nein, anonymes
Objekt geht auch nicht, habe ich auch schon ausprobiert, okay, wir müssen jetzt mal versuchen
nachzuvollziehen, wie, wie hat sich das Microsoft gedacht, wie hat sich das Microsoft gedacht,
wie es gibt doch chasen value, eben, hä, bin ich jetzt total verwirrt, eben, eben gab
es das doch nicht, oder, oder wahrscheinlich einfach hier, hier, hier drinnen nicht, chasen
value, create, sowas hier vielleicht in der Richtung, ich müsste, es muss doch, es muss
doch sowas geben wie insert raw, raw value oder sowas, sowas, sowas suche ich, raw value,
sowas hier machen könnte, probieren wir das mal aus, na das wird nicht gehen, oder, echt,
okay, er ist, er ist schon mal der Meinung, dass es kompiliert und wir wissen ja alle
von der Endpunkt, wenn es kompiliert, dann geht es, hey, nice, das funktioniert, man
muss einfach nur wissen, wie, sehr schön, guckt und jetzt kann ich mehrere Sensoren
anlegen und ich kann immer wieder das gleiche verwenden, das, das ist doch schon mal, das
ist doch schon mal gut, jetzt haben wir auch was gelernt, wobei das jetzt ja nur die halbe
Miete war, also ich weiß jetzt wie ich meine Sensoren anlege, gut, so mal in mich gehen
und wie könnten wir das denn jetzt, ich will es jetzt nicht gar so, gar so übertreiben,
ich will jetzt nicht 50.000 Unterklassen oder so machen, aber man könnte ja für so einen
Sensor eine eigene Klasse machen, dass man zum Beispiel sagt, ja, aber müsste identifiers
nicht ein JSON Array sein, das ist korrekt, das wird so nicht funktionieren, also müsste
Identifier eigentlich sowas sein, mache ich denn das jetzt am besten, gibt es da sowas
wie Serialize S, dass ich dem sagen kann, lass das aus, JSON Ignore, kann ich ihm sagen,
JSON Ignore, ach ja, gar nicht, ach Quatsch, ich bin doch hier komplett falsch, das muss
hier oben, siehst du, das ist das blöde, wenn das alles in einer Datei drin ist, dann
siehst du überhaupt nicht wo du steckst, wo du bist, hier müssen wir hin, JSON Ignore,
also, doch, doch, es gab einen Array, aber da müsste ich das ja beim Anlegen auch so
angeben, also es gibt jetzt zwei Varianten, entweder ich mache das so und lege noch eine
zweite Sache an, die private ist, falls er das mit serialisiert, weiß ich nicht, oder
ich mache es einfach zu einem Array, wir machen das mal in zwei Schritten, also machen wir
ein String Array draus, Identifier, da muss ich wieder hochscrollen, genau, das wird auf
jeden Fall funktionieren so, achso, muss vielleicht noch angeben, was er ausgeben soll, so, ja,
das funktioniert auf jeden Fall so, aber was wir jetzt bei der Gelegenheit gerade nochmal
ausprobieren können, was ist, wenn ich sage, JSON Ignore, Property, ups, achso, das macht
keinen Sinn, String, Identifier, Identifiers, geht das sowas? Und was wir jetzt sagen, naja,
das ist wirklich Paintschamp, ich wollte jetzt sagen, wir können das Ignoren und wir können
aber sagen, wenn das hier, wenn das hier einer get macht, dann wollen wir in Wirklichkeit
haben, New, Dings, Identifier, gucken, ob das jetzt funktioniert, Identifier, hey, das
gefällt mir aber sogar besser, das gefällt mir besser, serialisiert er das auch, wenn
man es private macht? Ja, das serialisiert das, nee, macht er nicht, okay, das finde
ich jetzt aber beides irgendwie bisschen hässlich, oder? Ich glaube, ich glaube, ich glaube,
die einfachste Variante ist tatsächlich, wir lassen das einfach weg, get set, dann
ist wenigstens klar, wie es funktioniert, Identifiers, New, dann ist wenigstens klar,
was es ist, muss uns jetzt ja nicht übertreiben, gut, wunderbar, so können wir das lassen,
jetzt muss ich mir eher noch überlegen, wie kriege ich das denn jetzt so gescheit zusammengebaut,
ich meine, schön ist es, schön ist es nicht, könnte ich nicht die Klasse machen für,
MQTT oder HA, Device Discovery oder sowas, also könnte man, könnte man nicht sowas hier
machen, sondern Public, oder Interface, weiß ich nicht, ob das funktioniert, was ich jetzt
bastle, aber ich schreibe mal einfach, Interface HA, was weiß ich, Discovery, Discovery, alles
klar, ist es muss, das lassen wir jetzt so, Discovery, Discovery, so, dass wir irgendwie
da Interface machen und dann machen wir irgendwie Classes dafür, sowas wie zum Beispiel Public,
Class, oh jetzt mag er nicht mehr, es ist irgendwie Procken, dann sowas wie MQTT Switch,
und dann sowas wie Sensor, Sensor, irgendwie sowas und beide, so, irgendwie so, von der
Hierarchie her und damit das dann funktioniert, braucht jeder Sensor, vielleicht mache ich
da gar kein Interface, sondern irgendeine Base Class dafür, weil was soll ich in das
Interface groß reinschreiben, ne, also was braucht denn so ein Sensor, damit das funktioniert,
der braucht den MQTT Client, sonst geht es nicht, sonst kann er nicht subscriben und
nicht Messages pushen und er braucht ein, wie habe ich das genannt, HA Device Info, HA
Device Info, was, wir machen jetzt mal die Noob Variante, wir nehmen jetzt einfach nur
den Switch, ohne irgendwelche Abhängigkeiten, weg damit, weg damit und gucken wir mal, ob
das funktioniert, so, das könnte man doch da drin relativ gut kapseln, wir lagern das
alles mal in der eigenen Datei aus, weil mittlerweile, jetzt wird es mir zu viel, jetzt blinke ich
hier nicht mehr durch, so, da muss ich nichts dran machen, das kommt auch in der eigenen,
nein, jebaited hat es mich, es hat mich zum löschen jebaited, ok, jetzt aber, move, move
new file, warum geht denn das, eben hat das doch noch funktioniert, Refactor, move to
another file, jawoll, bäm, da sind wir, Info, Device Info, ok, also, das heißt, anstatt
dass ich diesen ganzen Krämpel hier mache, machen wir das hier mal weg, aber das machen
wir das hier auch mal weg, so, machen wir mal zack, kommentieren wir das mal aus, so,
anstatt sich den ganzen Mist hier mache, könnte ich doch einfach sagen, ähm, da oben können
wir eigentlich auch mal wegmachen, so, dass ich den ganzen Mist hier mache, einfach in
new, ah, mqtt switch, switch, und der kriegt den kleinen übergeben und, ok, das root device
zu nennen ist natürlich schon doof, nennen wir es einfach, device info, genau, moin,
was ist das für ein Editor, das ist Ryder, genau, jetbrains, das sind die gleichen Leute,
die auch IntelliJ machen, die für die Java-Fans unter uns, hat jemand von euch die Ehre,
auf der Arbeit Java zu programmieren, wir sind da, wie lang sind wir schon, Alter, wir
sind 4 Stunden fast schon zu Gange, ernsthaft, war ne blöde Frage, ist jemand auch schon
fast 4 Stunden, ist jemand schon 4 Stunden hier, das Stripes ist glaube ich, bis am
Ende, fast von Anfang an da, meine Güte, lull, fast, Wahnsinn, ja nice, dass ihr so
lange am Start seid, es ist ja schon ein bisschen trocken vielleicht, ja, gebe ich zu, aber
was soll ich machen, der Heiz-Champ muss funktionieren, nix Java, nur Jaml-Programmierung, Jaml-Programmierung
ist meine Lieblings-Programmiersprache, also ich würde sagen, Jaml, aber dicht gefolgt
von HTML programmieren, ist beides ungefähr auf einer Ebene, allerdings, ich persönlich
sehe das Ganze ja nicht so eng, also wenn jemand zu mir sagt, wenn ich mir vorstelle, wir haben
einen neuen Azubi und ich frage ihn so nach dem Motto, und wie sieht es in dem Bereich
aus, wie sieht es in dem Bereich aus, und wir kommen irgendwie auf Programmiersprachen
oder so, und er sagt mir, er kann HTML programmieren, ich werde nicht den Klugscheißer machen von
wegen HTML ist keine Programmiersprache, ich finde das vollkommen in Ordnung, wenn einer
sagt, er kann HTML programmieren, ich weiß nicht, warum er da immer so ein Akt machen
soll, HTML ist mittlerweile so komplex, ja, und hat so viele Dinger drin, es mag formell
keine Programmiersprache sein, aber das ist XML auch nicht, oder JSON, oder Jaml, oder
was auch immer, das ist auch keine Programmiersprache, aber trotzdem, gerade Jaml kannst du so viele
Sachen damit konfigurieren, und je nachdem, guckt euch mal sowas wie Ansible an zum Beispiel,
Ansible ist Jaml, aber du kannst in Ansible, dadurch wie das Jaml interpretiert wird,
das kann man dann schon Programmieren nennen, weil da in Ansible hast du Logik drin, hast
du Schleifen drin, hast du Variablen drin, wenn du ein Kind hast, dann nennst du es JSON,
aber bist du nicht der Einzige, ich glaube das haben wir noch mehr probiert, wenn ich
ein Kind habe, dann würde ich es Bashen Alter Bashen nennen, oder Codra, nein, also wenn
ich ein Kind hätte, würde ich, boah habe ich mir noch gar keine Gedanken drüber gemacht,
wie würde ich mein Kind nennen, ich bevorzuge es eigentlich gar kein Kind zu nennen, xxderkindxx,
genau xxderkindxx, das ist es, so wird es heißen, nee, da habe ich mir noch keine Gedanken
drüber gemacht, ich habe es auch nicht vor, wenn es sich vermeiden lässt, naja, das kommt
ja auch noch dazu, also erstens gibt es ja aus mehreren Gründen, kann das, funktioniert
das ja aktuell nicht, mir fehlt aktuell die Voraussetzung dazu, da man braucht hier irgendjemand,
mit dem man Kinder kriegen kann, zusammen, und das nächste ist, ich habe absolut keinen
Bock auf Kinder, Kinder gehen mir so unglaublich auf die Nerven, ich will gar keine, also kommt
ja auch noch dabei, Kinders, ja, ich bin heute wieder im Kindergarten vorbeigelaufen auf
dem Rückweg vom Rewe, und das Geschrei ging mir schon so auf den Keks, boah, nehmen wir
mal auf, nee, das ist nix für mich, was halten, was halten Sie von VeraCrypt, das wird jetzt
aber äußerst förmlich heute, ich habe selbst VeraCrypt, ich finde VeraCrypt sehr sinnvoll,
wenn man Microsoft traut, kann man natürlich auch BitLocker verwenden, aber VeraCrypt
ist somit das Sinnvollste, was man machen kann mit seiner Windows Installation, und
es geht gar nicht so sehr darum, dass, keine Ahnung, das FBI vor der Tür steht, darüber
mache ich mir nämlich auch keine Gedanken, ich benutze VeraCrypt und Festplattenverschlüsselung
aus einem ganz einfachen Bequemlichkeitsgrund, also das erste ist, es ist nicht deutlich,
es ist kaum langsamer als nicht verschlüsselte Festplatten, also das ist ein fast nicht feststellbarer
Unterschied, und das nächste ist, du kannst Festplatten einfach auf den Müll schmeißen
und du musst dir keine Gedanken machen ums Löschen, oder dass irgendjemand wieder irgendwann
irgendwas herstellen kann, und noch anders, wenn die Festplatte kaputt ist, und du kannst
sie nicht ordnungsgemäß löschen, was machst du da mit deiner Festplatte? Willst du die
wirklich mit sensiblen Sachen vielleicht wegschmeißen, sodass sie doch eventuell noch einer restoren
kann? Das Problem kann man komplett mit Festplatten Vollverschlüsselung lösen, du hast einfach
die Gausa, du kannst natürlich auch wie Google machen und da irgendwelche Bolzen durchbohren,
wie ich schon gesehen habe, aber das einfachste ist tatsächlich die Festplatte zu verschlüsseln,
wenn die Festplatte verschlüsselt ist, dann hast du keine Probleme, du kannst sie quasi
nehmen, Fenster aufmachen und raus pfeffern und du musst dir keine Gedanken mehr drüber
machen. Das ist der praktische Faulheitsgrund bei mir, warum ich Festplatten Vollverschlüsselung
auf den Geräten habe. Ich will einfach die Festplatte oder die SSD nehmen können, raus
roppen, auf den Müll schmeißen können und ich muss mir keine Gedanken machen, dass
irgendjemand dran kommt. Ja, SSD ist ja das nächste. SSD zerstören ist gar nicht mal
so einfach, das sei denn du schmilzt sie ein. Übrigens, das ist auch schon was, wo ich mir
Gedanken drüber gemacht habe. Ich habe hier jede Menge ESP32 und ESP866 hier irgendwo
rumfliegen, nicht alle in Benutzung, aber geflasht mit Wi-Fi Credentials, WLAN Passwort und so,
ich habe mir auch schon überlegt, die kannst du eigentlich nicht wegschmeißen, weil dort
im Flash von der Firmware oder eben im normalen Flash stehen meine WLAN Zugangsdaten. Eigentlich
kann ich die Dinger gar nicht wegschmeißen. Ich habe mir auch schon überlegt, was mache
ich denn damit jetzt? Und ich habe mir überlegt, das beste wäre eigentlich irgendwie einschmelzen,
aber schmelz mal so einen PCB mit Metall ein, das ist gar nicht so einfach, das einzuschmelzen.
Einfach öfters die WLAN Credentials rotieren. Ja, das habe ich mir auch schon gedacht, aber
das ist mit jede Menge China-Camera-Geräten, wo du dich dann wirklich auf jedem Gerät
einloggen musst und alles ändern, gar nicht so einfach. Deswegen habe ich jetzt aktuell
bestimmt schon ein Jahr meine WLAN Credentials nicht mehr geändert, aber das ist halt auch
ein richtig ewig langes Passwort. Was ich auch ein bisschen doof finde, dass es mit dem
normalen WLAN Authentifizierung keine Möglichkeit gibt, Authentifizierung nur für ein Gerät
zu machen. Dass man quasi sagt, hey, oder mehrere User, ich weiß, dass das geht, das
geht mit Enterprise-Authentifizierung, aber tja, macht es mal mit normalen Endgeräten.
Ja, also dass man zum Beispiel sagen könnte, hey, für diese SSID gibt es fünf verschiedene
User, weil dann könnte man auch Wegwerf-User machen, die man wieder löscht. Das ist alles
nicht so schön. Nicht so big brain. Können die China-Geräte nicht raten? Das meine ich
ja. Aber einen ESP32 oder einen ESP86 habe ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt noch nie explizit
geguckt, aber ich würde mich sehr wundern, wenn die Enterprise-Authentifizierung könnten
fürs WLAN. Gucken wir nochmal, ESP32, WLAN, oder wir können auch Radios suchen, aber wir
haben Enterprise hier. Können die bestimmt nicht. Hä, das hat doch damit überhaupt nichts
zu tun. Was schreiben die denn da für komische Dinge wieder? Hä? Das hat doch überhaupt
nichts mit, ähm, was? Zertifikat? Ganz davon abgesehen, weiß jemand, ob man Enterprise-Authentifizierung
und normale Authentifizierung parallel laufen lassen kann für die gleiche SSID? Das geht
ja glaube ich auch nicht, ne? Also anscheinend geht das. Vielleicht geht das doch, aber es
ist halt dann auch schon ein bisschen aufwendig. So, wir machen jetzt noch, wir machen jetzt
noch ein paar Sachen. Aber Leute, also ich bin jetzt noch, ich bin noch eine Stunde umgefahren,
dann gehe ich was essen. Du könntest ja alternativ mehrere SSIDs mit unterschiedlichen Passwörtern
machen. Ja, das könnte ich machen. Das mache ich ja auch so. Das mache ich ja auch so.
Das ändert aber nichts daran, dass es nicht einfach ist, Passwörter zu rotieren. Weil,
wenn man, wenn man eine SSID haben könnte und die Geräte alle Enterprise-Authentifizierung
unterstützen, dann könnte man nämlich einfach für jedes Endgerät eine extra User anlegen
und wenn man das Endgerät wegwirft, löscht man einfach den User und fertig. Das wäre
die einfachste Variante. Einfach mit der Bohrmaschine den 32 aufbauen. Ja, das geht. Natürlich,
du kannst das Ding schon physisch zerstören, klar. Aber es ist gar nicht mal so einfach.
Wirklich. Also nachhaltig, also wenn die nachhaltig ist, es ist gar nicht so einfach. Sagen wir,
nennen wir hier so wie Monster T1 Mini. Zerstör das mal so, dass nix mehr auslesbar ist. Klar,
du kannst da, du kannst da schon durchbohren. Und es wird wahrscheinlich in 99 Prozent
der Fällen auch der Fall sein, dass es dann hoffnungslos kaputt ist. Aber sagen wir mal
so, es ist keine, es ist keine wirklich gute, gute Variante. Also einfacher wär's, du hättest
irgendeinen Häcksler, dann würdest du das reinschmeißen und der häckst, der häckselt dir das. Aber
das, du wirst nix für einen Privatbereich finden, der dir sowieso Metalldinger kleinschreddern
kann. Oder du schmilzt das ein, was du bei den Dämpfen, die das ab sondert, bestimmt
auch nicht haben willst. Mac Whitelisting. Nee, das bringt nix. Das geht, aber das ist
nicht Weisheitsletzter Schluss. Ja, also ja, man müsste eigentlich, eigentlich müsste
man sich lokal, wie einer im Chat geschrieben hat, in irgendein Unternehmen suchen, was
das schreddert und dann nimmt man ne Tüte mit. Ich hab bestimmt mittlerweile 2030 so
kleine Techniksachen mit WLAN-Cutentials zu entsorgen, schmeißt die da in die Häckslermaschine
und ja, ihr wisst, was ich mein. Das wär natürlich das Beste. So, also wie gesagt,
alle Stunde bin ich noch da. Wir machen jetzt noch mal eine Sache. Kannst du das bitte noch
mal vertonen? Nee, reicht jetzt. Der Brofessor. Ja, schick ich dir alle, gar kein Ding. Ich
weiß, der Chat, also dem Chat vertraue ich mit Abstand am meisten, mein WLAN-Passwort
vertraulich zu behandeln. Okay Leute, ich muss jetzt noch mal in mich gehen. Wir machen
jetzt noch mal, wir machen jetzt noch in die letzte Stunde, in den letzten 5 Minuten, wir
machen jetzt noch was sinnvolles. Ich will das jetzt mal ein bisschen, bisschen ordentlicher
hier zusammenfassen. Also, Switch, New, HA, MQTT, Switch. Wir übergeben ein MQTT Klein
und ein Device Info. Das ist doch schon mal fein. Sehr, sehr nice. Ist das nice. So,
lasst jetzt mal in mich gehen. Wie können wir das jetzt halbwegs sinnvoll encapsulieren?
Ich würde sagen, wir legen uns erstmal ein paar Variablen an für die unterschiedlichen
Topics, die wir brauchen. Also Private Read Only String. Was brauchen wir? Wir brauchen
ein State Topic. Wir brauchen ein State Topic. Wir brauchen ein Config Topic, also für MQTT
und wir brauchen ein Command Topic. Das haben wir hier alles schon angegeben für Command
Topic, State Topic, sonst was. So, wie bauen wir uns das denn zusammen? Also, wir fangen
an mit dem Config Topic. So, das Config Topic setzt sich zusammen. Ich muss das mal kurz
Copy Pasten, sonst komme ich da im Leben nicht drauf. Also, wie setzt sich das denn jetzt
zusammen? Das ist immer Home Assistant Switch ID. Ja, was ist denn? Warte mal, was ist denn
nochmal die ID? Ne, die ID ist Identifier. Device Info Identifiers ist das. Die kann
ich ja dafür nehmen. Das ist ja Identifiers, das ist in dem Fall halt Heidschamp. Ist ja
relativ, relativ unique. Ich glaube, was anderes mit Heidschamp habe ich nicht. Wobei ich das
immer noch nicht schön finde, muss ich ehrlich sagen. Ich fände das viel cooler, wenn das
noch die, wenn das noch die MAC Adresse dran hängt. Wenn das nämlich die MAC Adresse
noch mit dabei hängt, dann kann ich mir wirklich sicher sein, das ist immer das gleiche vom
gleichen Gerät aus und wenn ich mehrere Heidschamps habe, was schwachsinnig ist, was ich nicht
habe, aber was ich haben könnte, dann hätte das, ja gut, aber ich könnte es ja auch auf
dem, auf der gleichen Kiste mehrere laufen. Na gut, irgendwann, irgendwann ist auch mal
gut. Irgendwann ist auch mal gut, ich muss es nicht übertreiben. Ich meine, hier mache
ich das ja schon so. Guck, DNS Name, Hostname und MAC. Das ist eigentlich, das ist eigentlich
ganz sinnvoll. Das machen wir jetzt. Du wolltest die ID von der Heizung nehmen? Stimmt, das
ist richtig. Die ID von der Heizung wollte ich nehmen. Die müssen wir jetzt erst mal
abfragen, die ID von der Heizung. Moment, wie frage ich die ID von der Heizung ab?
Die ID von der Heizung abfragen, wo haben wir es denn hier? Heizchamp, wo ist der Heizchamp?
Habe ich das, kann es sein, dass ich das gelöscht habe? Client, Endpoint, IP Endpoint, stimmt,
das habe ich gelöscht. Habe ich das gelöscht? Ja, ich bin bescheuert, ich habe es weggeschmissen.
Also, was war die IP von dem Respondent im Keller? 1.129, oder? Port 3002. So, wie Client?
Ich weiß nicht mehr. Q-Commands, musste man glaube ich sagen und dann Get Inventory war
es glaube ich. Ich kann immer schreiben. Get Inventory. Das ist auch noch ziemlich kacke
gemacht hier mit der Heizungskommunikation. Ah, ich muss warten. Das ist alles kacke gebaut,
das muss ich mir noch mal ordentliches überlegen. Ja, das ist die ID von meiner Heizung. 004EE9C9,
warum auch immer Null da hinten dran stehen muss, aber Null. Das ist mir egal, ob da Null
hinten dran steht oder nicht. Das ist hier die ID von der Heizung. Wenn man halt mal ganz
klar sagen muss, die ID von der Heizung ist eigentlich auch nicht wirklich so sinnvoll.
Das werde ich mir nämlich richtig überlege, weil die ID von der Heizung ist ja immer die
gleiche, aber ich könnte ja theoretisch mehrere Geräte haben, die das abfragen, was schwachsinnig
ist. Ja, ich weiß, also ich habe ein Gerät, was das abfragt und gut ist. Ich muss es nicht
übertreiben, aber nur rein von der Logik her. Ich könnte natürlich mehrere Geräte haben,
deswegen ist die Kombination mit Hostname und MAC-Adresse eigentlich besser. Wir machen
das jetzt einfach. Scheiß drauf. Wir machen das jetzt einfach mit der MAC-Adresse vom
Host. Das können wir nämlich da hier reinpacken. Guck mal, das können wir in die andere Klasse
packen. Wir haben noch hier ein HA Device Info. Dann können wir das einfach hier reinpacken.
Diese Sache mit MAC-Adresse auslesen. High Availability Heizungsabfrag mit Hotspair komplett
normaler Szenar. Was heißt das hier mit Hotspair? Mit Cold Standby Heizung. Hotswap. Max, wie
bedienst du eigentlich deinen Home Assistant? Hast du irgendeine Fernbedienung dazu oder
ein zweckentfremdes Tablet? Mehrere Sachen. Ich habe einmal natürlich auf meinem Smartphone,
da ist das drauf zum Steuern auf meinem iPad. Dann hat auf dem anderen iPad auch noch und
ich habe im Flur oben und unten, für den Flur oben und unten habe ich jeweils an der Wand
noch einen Amazon Fire HD 10. Sind das die großen? Fire HD 10? Genau. Die gibt es nämlich
immer relativ günstig. Warum? Hä? Warum ist denn das so teuer auf einmal? Na gut, wahrscheinlich
weil keine Aktion ist. Die gibt es immer relativ günstig, wenn man irgendwelche Aktionen abwartet.
Also bei Amazon, es gibt ja mittlerweile so viel Zeugs bei Amazon. Black Friday, Cyber
Monday, Black Friday Week, September Specials, Prime Day. Die haben ja gefühlt jeden Monat
irgendwas. Und das Einzige, was sich eigentlich immer lohnt, wenn man das braucht, ist Amazon
Geräte bei Amazon zu kaufen, wenn die solche Aktionen haben, weil die sind immer relativ
günstig. Und da habe ich mir damals auch zwei Fire HD 10 gekauft. Jetzt kosten die 150,
ich glaube, ich habe damals 79 oder so dafür bezahlt. Also irgendwie die Hälfte oder 89
oder sowas. Ohne Werbung ist ja lächerlich. Das ist viel zu teuer. Das würde ich lieber
flashen oder deploaten und dann ist es weg. Ja, so zwei habe ich an der Wand hängen. Wie
ich die befestigt habe? Gar nicht. Ich habe glücklicherweise genau im richtigen Abstand
das Telefon von der Türgegensprecherlage hängen, diese Box, und ich kann die genau
so halb hinter die Box und an die Wand schieben, dass es sich quasi da reinklemmt. Ich habe
keine Halterung gebraucht, wo ich wirklich sehr froh drüber bin, weil ich keinen Bock
habe, in die Wand irgendwelche Löcher zu bohren. Strom. Strom bohr, das könnte ich dir auf
Bild zeigen, wenn ich das Bild finden würde. Der Chat weiß das bestimmt. Image, Image,
Uhr. Ich habe keine Ahnung mehr. Ich habe davon Bilder und die habe ich auch mal im Stream
gezeigt. Ich habe durch den durch das Leerrohr, wo Moment, ich kann es dir zeigen. Aha. Ich
habe doch letztens irgendwas gepostet. Ich weiß aber bloß nicht, ob das offen war oder
nicht. Die Abdeckung davon. Übrigens auch so ein Ding, wo es sich extrem gelohnt hat,
eine Firma zu flaschen. Standardmäßig hält das Ding ein halbes Jahr, dann ist die Batterie
leer. Und jetzt bin ich irgendwie bei 88 Prozent nach einem Dreivierteljahr oder so. Hier.
Man sieht es nicht. By the way, das sieht nicht mehr so aus. Das war Testaufbau. Hups.
Nee, komm an. Oder kann ich? Sieht nicht mehr so aus. Also ich habe durch den durch das
Leerrohr was hier. Also hier oben ist normalerweise das Tablet. Hier ist das Tablet dazwischen
geklemmt. Das passt genau dahin. Und ich habe durch das Leerrohr, wo die ganzen Sachen hier
sind, habe ich im Keller einen 12 Volt Netzteil angeschlossen, da angeklemmt an zwei freie
Adern und in jedem Telefonkasten habe ich einen 12 Volt auf 5 Volt Spannungswandler drin,
wo ich dann per USB die Tablets versorge, die hier dranhängen. Das hier ist übrigens
das USB Kabel fürs Tablet, was hier runterhängt. Glaub ich zumindest. Oder auch nicht. Das
müsste eigentlich das Kabel vom Tablet sein. Also hier, genau, hier kommt ein USB Kabel
raus und das kann ich dann hier ins Tablet stecken. Was für Wandglas du denn da. China-Chinesen
Aliexpress von Amazon. So rote. Also im Prinzip ein bisschen sowas wie der hier, nur dass
es anders aussieht. Ja, sowas hier in der Richtung. Warte mal, ich guck mal kurz, ich
guck mal kurz auf dem Handy, dann kann ich dir sagen, wie das Ding hieß. Amazon. Orders.
Was suche ich denn da jetzt? USB. Wenn ich nach USB suche, finde ich 50 Seiten. FTDI
Tablet. Okay, nach USB hätte ich nicht suchen dürfen. Meine Güter habe ich schon viel gekauft
mit USB drinne. Das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf. Hier, da ist es doch. Ich hab's gefunden.
Dual USB 12 Volt. Sag mal, ich sehe es doch gerade bei mir auf dem Handy. Das Ding habe
ich. Amazon hat es nicht gefunden, weil es nicht verfügbar ist. So einen Teil kriegst
du bestimmt tausendfach hier noch. Guck da, alle möglichen. Das ist China-Chinesen Zeug,
kostet 3,50 Euro oder so. Guck hier, wie viel sind denn das? Fünfer Pack für 10 Euro.
Du zahlst ja zwei Euro das Stück. Guck mal, die sind sogar mittlerweile 6 bis 40 Volt
zu 5 Volt. Wobei ich mich frage, ob 40, das wird ein bisschen warm, oder? 12 auf 5 ist
kein Problem, funktioniert ohne Dinger. Ja, die habe ich hier oben drinne. Aus dem Leerrohr
in der Wand kommt dann halt das Kabel, 12, 12 Volt DC drauf. Da oben in der Ecke habe
ich mit Klebeband das Kram reingemacht und hier vorne hast du einen USB-Kabel raus. Es
müssen übrigens tatsächlich, also man könnte sich jetzt natürlich fragen, warum habe ich
im Keller einen 12 Volt-Netzteil angeschlossen und nicht einen 5 Volt-Netzteil, wie man für
USB braucht? Ist doch ein Schaltregler das höhere Spann? Ich bin immer wieder überrascht,
wie viele Elektrik-Stellleute wir hier im Chat haben, habe ich überhaupt keine Ahnung
von. Ich glaube euch das jetzt einfach mal. Also Big Brain Chat wieder. Ja, und das muss
ich machen, weil 5 Volt ist in ersten Stock drauf, ist die Spannung zu gering, dann laden
die Tablets nicht. Also wenn ich einen 5 Volt-Netzteil im Keller anschließe und von dort dann ins
Erdgeschoss ans Tablet und durch das Leerrohr in ersten Stock gehe, dann habe ich oben,
ich habe es mal gemessen, ich habe oben dann noch irgendwie 4 Volt oder irgendwie sowas
übrig gehabt von den 5 oder 3,8 oder sowas und das hat sich, das hat halt gesagt, da hat
das Tablet nicht mal geladen. Also zumindest das Tablet, doch das stimmt nicht, das Tablet
hat geladen, aber das Tablet hat quasi schneller verbraucht als geladen, obwohl es im Stand
By war. Also konntest du vergessen. Und das Problem hast du bei 12 Volt nicht, umso höher
die Spannung, umso weniger hast du da Probleme. Und jetzt, vielleicht kommen jetzt von den
12 oben noch 11,5 oder so an und dann geht das in den Spannungswandler rein und dann
direkt per USB ans Tablet. Ist echt ganz praktisch, hast du keinerlei Kabelsalat, also
das ist ja nicht normal hier. Das hier war mein Testaufbau für Tür-Gegensprechanlage
zu Fritzbox, also zu Deckt, zu Telefon. Der übrigens jetzt im Keller steht und wunderbar
funktioniert. Der Chat hat mich übrigens auf die Idee gebracht, muss ich nochmal sagen.
Es gibt einen Mikrocontroller, den du mit.NET programmieren kannst, ja. Ich glaube irgendwie
so heißt der Kram. Ist aber relativ teuer, ist für Low-Power-Szenarien jetzt auch nicht
so sinnvoll und dazu kommt, dass sie die ganzen Libraries fehlen. Ich hab die gebacked auf
Kickstarter damals. Ich hab so ein Ding hier. Ich hab die auf Kickstarter gebacked, weil
ich das eine richtig coole Idee fand und es ist eigentlich auch eine coole Idee. Also
auch Performance mäßig ist das wunderbar das Teil. Das hat einen ESP32 drauf plus
einen STM32, also du hast da viele, viele Dinge drauf. Also an sich eine richtig coole
Idee. Das hauptsächliche Problem ist, dass dir komplett alle Libraries fehlen. Willst
du irgendeinen LCD-Display ansteuern? Ja Pech gehabt. Klar, du kannst das natürlich von
Hand machen, weil das ist dann wahrscheinlich irgendein I2C-Display oder so, aber das willst
du ja nicht. Du willst irgendeine Display-Library, dass du sagen kannst, hier String in die linke
obere Ecke oder so. Dir fehlen schlicht und ergreifend, es gibt kein.NET Mikrocontroller
Ökosystem. Es gibt noch das Mikroframework oder sowas, das hast du aber ähnliche Probleme.
Es ist, leider ist.NET keine gute Mikrocontroller Plattform. Ich würde mir wünschen, dass es
anders wäre, ihr wisst, ich bin ein großer.NET Fanboy. Aber da kommste um C, leider
bzw. leider C++, was ja so ziemlich das menschenverachteste ist, was es irgendwie gibt, kommste leider
nicht drum herum. Es gibt noch andere Varianten, es gibt beispielsweise
Micro-Python gibt es noch oder Lua, aber das hat ähnliche Probleme. Micro-Python dürfte
auch das mitverbreiteste sein neben C und C++. Es gab auch mal Versuche für Rust. Im Prinzip
ist es alles Müll, du kommst nicht dran vorbei. Du musst C bzw. C++ wenn es Arduino ist verwenden.
Keine Chance. Haben sie Core-RT nicht sogar eingestellt?
Tiny-Go, ja Tiny-Go wäre cool, wenn das funktioniert, aber Tiny-Go geht glaube ich auf dem ESP32
statt. Oder doch. Aber Tiny-Go hat auch so die Probleme,
die fehlen halt die ganzen Libraries. Das ist halt, das ist sacked halt einfach nur.
Ja, aber es gibt keine gescheite Build-Environment für Rust auf dem ESP32, also das letzte was
ich gesehen habe war von zwei Jahren aktualisiert. Deswegen, also das gesamte Ökosystem, gerade
wenn man die Arduino-kompatiblen Sachen verwenden will, also du kannst eigentlich nur C++ verwenden.
Das ist halt doof, weil ich wie gesagt, für mich ist C++ somit das painst-champigste was
es gibt. Ich weiß nicht was mit dem C++-Cremium los ist, aber viel schlimmer als C++ geht
es eigentlich kaum noch. Da würde ich lieber Fortran oder Cobalt programmieren, bevor
ich C++ programmiere, aber es ist leider das einzig benutzbare.
So, jetzt schauen wir mal kurz weiter. Also Host-Info. Übrigens Leute, ich merke leider,
dass ich auch langsam nicht mehr richtig nachdenken kann. Schon so lange on, aber das machen wir
noch kurz. Fertig. Übrigens, wem das Stream gefällt und auch Prime-Sub übrig hat, ich
würde mich freuen. Ich habe mir auch vorgenommen, ich bin in nächster Zeit wieder öfters da.
Ich habe jetzt seit den letzten drei Wochen, ich habe mich durch so viele Dinge ablenken
lassen. Ihr habt ja auch gesehen, ich habe auf YouTube kaum was gemacht. Ich war auch
auf Twitter nicht so aktiv und auch auf Twitch. Ich habe alles Mögliche zusammen. Ich muss
daheim viel basteln. Ich habe ein neues RPG am Start, wo ich relativ viel spiele. Alle
möglichen Sachen. Aber ich habe mir vorgenommen, ich streame jetzt wieder mehr.
Conifreak, Dankeschön für den Prime-Sub. Exzellent, exzellent. Einfach Kreisel-Krime-Stream.
Ich spiele kein MMORPG. Ich spiele das neue Pathfinder Singleplayer RPG, was ziemlich gut
geworden ist. Was ziemlich gut geworden ist, muss ich sagen. Kingmaker war schon nice.
Also das, das hier meine ich. Kingmaker war schon nice. Steam mochte Kingmaker nicht,
weil die Leute zu dumm waren, den ersten Dungeon zu packen. Kann ich wirklich nur empfehlen.
Das Spiel hat ein paar Bugs, aber es ist wirklich ein enorm riesig umfangreiches RPG. Du kannst
locker 100 plus Stunden den Singleplayer spielen, ohne dass du alles gemacht hast. Also kann
ich wirklich nur empfehlen. Er ist was, was mit Steam immer los ist.
Naja. Das ist wirklich nice. Also das kann man echt nur empfehlen. Ja, die Steam-Bewertungen
sind teilweise wieder ein bisschen... Die Steam-Bewertungen sind ein bisschen painstampig.
Ja, das hat schon ein paar Bugs, aber es ist bei weitem nicht so schlimm, was da Steam
draus macht. Und die Leute auf Steam sind wieder komplett unfähig. Da redet die Leute sich
dann drüber aufregend, dass sie irgendwelche Gegner nicht down bekommen. Die müssen einfach
mal in die Infos von den Gegnern reingucken, wo dann drinsteht, du musst Elektro-Damage
machen, dass sie sterben. Das steht alles da. Steam ist wieder komplett unfähig. Aber am
schlimmsten fand ich die Bewertung bei dem letzten Pathfinder-Game von Steam, wo die
Leute wirklich negative Bewertungen gegeben haben, nach irgendwie zwei Stunden Spielen,
weil sie den ersten Dungeon nicht geschafft haben. Ihr müsst wissen, in dem ersten Dungeon
gibt es komplett Lost. In dem ersten Dungeon gab es quasi so Insekten-Schwärme als Gegner.
Das war ein Übungs-Dungeon. Und das Game sagt dir, bevor du in den Dungeon gehst, nimm
dir Brandbomben mit oder Feuerzauber. Ehe Feuerzauber. Das sagt das Spiel. Und die Leute
auf Steam, can't beat first dungeon, balance suck, overtune shit. Erstmal voll abgeraged
wieder. Einfach zu dumm gewesen. Das ist bei solchen Games leider so. Die Leute auf Steam
sind einfach hängen geblieben. Ja, irgendjemand hat auch was gesagt mit der Inventory-Nummer
von Heizungen. Man hat auch gerade was geschrieben, wo ich noch was zu sagen wollte. Die Aldi der
Heizung ist doch sinnvoll. Du schaltest ja die Heizung nicht den Kleinen, der die Heizung
schaltet. Jaja, das ist richtig. Deswegen, es würde eigentlich auch komplett reichen,
wenn ich die Heizungs-ID nehme. Aber ich könnte ja doch zwei verschiedene. Zum Beispiel,
Nummern und Beispiel. Wenn ich da jetzt hardcoded reinschreiben würde, die Heizungs-ID. Ich
stelle dir vor, ich lasse das Programm unten auf dem Raspberry Pi laufen. Dort, wo auch
die ganze Heizungs-Geschichte drauf läuft. Aber ich möchte zum Testen bei mir lokal das
Ganze noch mal ausführen. Dann würde ich bei beiden mich bei Home Assistant mit der
gleichen ID melden. Deswegen ist es vielleicht mit Hostname und MAC-Adresse doch sinnvoller.
Deswegen machen wir das jetzt einfach mal. Also, ich lese die MAC-Adresse aus. Ich lese
mein Hostname aus. Da kommt dann hier sowas bei rum. Und da bauen wir jetzt einfach mal
Identifier zusammen. Identifier. Das sind so Wörter, aber denen tue ich mir immer total
schwer, die zu schreiben. Das sind so ein paar Wörter. Identifier ist einer davon. So,
Hostname und Underscore und dann die MAC-Adresse. Jawoll. Gehen wir mal aus, ob das jetzt sinnvoll
ist, was da rauskommt. Aha, wunderbar. Warte mal, ich muss wieder Hust-Champ machen. Alter.
Ja. Nice. Vielleicht doch. Ich mache nachher. Ich habe mir beim Lidl ein Corona-Test geholt.
Naso-Check-Comfort. Den mache ich nachher mal. Ich bin die ganze Zeit schon am Husten. Ich
bin geimpft, muss ich sagen. Also eigentlich sollte ich nichts kriegen. Aber du weißt ja
nie. Corona. Hast du noch andere? Nein, ich habe wahrscheinlich kein Corona. Ich habe
ein Fieber, glaube ich zumindest, und nichts. Ich habe gar nichts. Ich habe nur Husten.
Husten und irgendwie was im Hals. Das ist richtig. Sonntags ab 10 ungefähr machen
wir immer ein gemeinsames Video gucken. Aufwacht. Stells Stream. Time. Also random Frage. Weshalb
mit C-Sharpen und nicht mit Pies? Also, äh, die Frage kannst du genauso gut umgedreht
stellen. Ich nehme das, womit ich am besten klarkomme bzw. was ich am liebsten
verwende. Die Frage kannst du ja im Prinzip in alle nur erdenklichen Richtungen stellen.
Zum Beispiel, wenn ich es mit Piesen gemacht hätte, käme jetzt irgendjemand an und sagt,
hey warum nicht mit Rust? Weil Performance und Rust beste. Oder warum nicht mit Go oder
Node.js oder was auch immer. Also es hat jetzt keinen spezifischen Grund, dass ich sagen
würde, ja ich muss das mit der Sprache machen, weil nur da gibt es XY was ich brauche. Ich
nehme einfach das was, warum nicht C++? Ja die Frage ist einfach zu beantworten, weil
C++ suckt. Aber das wusstest du, das war ja wirklich die Frage. Oder Cobol oder so.
Warum gibt es nicht, warum gibt es nicht eigentlich Kapperlang? Moment.
Warum gibt es das? Was?
Was? Was bin ich sehend? Alter. Ok, das ist credit-kappers-4. Ok, das ist mit zu hoch
jetzt jetzt vorbei. Kapperlang. This is stupid. Don't leave, look at it. Vor 5 Jahren. Kapperlang.
Code literally in... Es war doch klar, dass irgendjemand sowas schon gemacht hat. Brainfuck.
Brainfuck mit Twitch Emotes. Jawoll, da hat die Welt drauf gewartet. Endlich. Endlich.
Ja, das hat die Welt gebraucht. Kapperlang. Irgendwie war klar, dass es das gibt, oder?
Bevor war es klar. Ja. Was ist mit CacWlang? Das kannst du ja mal suchen. Ich glaube nicht,
dass es das gibt. Ich muss sagen, so bekannt CacW, CacW mittlerweile auf Twitch ist, aber
so Mainstream-technisch ist Kapper mit Abstand, aber wirklich sagen mit riesem Abstand das
bekannteste Twitch-Emote. Vielleicht Lull kennen die Leute auch noch, aber Kapper ist
das... CacW kennt jeder auf Twitch, aber Kapper ist das mit Abstand bekannteste. Was ich ja
auch lustig finde, weil es auf YouTube das nicht gibt, auf YouTube in den Comments, wenn
einer Kapper schreiben will, hat sich das jetzt ja durchgesetzt, weil YouTube mal die
ganze Zeit das da, oder das Schwarze, weil YouTube hat Kapper mal eine Zeit lang mit
diesem Symbol übersetzt, wenn du es geschrieben hast und deswegen schreiben die Leute lustig,
aber auf YouTube immer Full Moon with Pace. So, also wir machen jetzt eine Sache noch.
Wir machen jetzt kurz noch das mit der Mac-Adresse fertig und ihr merkt schon, ich habe schon
Probleme irgendwie richtig normal hier normal zu reden. Identifier. Also ich vergesse jetzt
schon sogar irgendwelche Typen da. Identifier. Das können wir eigentlich abkürzen, damit
man nicht doppelt zuweisen. Identifier, so und jetzt get new String Array Identifier.
Ja, so ist das doch ganz schick. Kann ich nämlich das mit Identifier rauslassen, da
wird jetzt komplett komplett selbst generated. Das finde ich gut. Peppelang gibt es auch,
da wundert mich nicht. Peppelang. Gibt es ein GitHub Eintrag? Esoteric Programming Language.
Das heißt, an der Anzahl der Es erkennt er irgendwas. Die Leute haben teilweise echt
zu viel Zeit. Peppelang gibt es wirklich. Bin immer wieder überrascht, dass es das
meiste, was mir an Schwachsinn einfällt, schon gibt. Aber eins gibt es noch nicht. Kekweseservice
gibt es nur hier. Kekweseservice. Nur das haben wir nur hier. Pass mal auf. Run. Run.
Also Kekweseservice ist das einzige. Guckt euch das mal an. Passt mal auf. Kekweseservice.
Also wer es noch nicht gesehen hat. Also der beste Microservice auf der Welt. Das ist das
nächste Millionen Startup. Ich sags euch. Der rotatet einfach random Kekw bei jedem
Seiten Refresh. Das hat die Welt gebraucht. Denke auch AWS fragt bald bezüglich Übernahme.
Ich kann zu den aktuellen Verhandlungen nichts sagen. Ist das öffentlich auf Git? Ja. Das
sind aber nur zwei Zeilen Code oder so. Das ist auf GitHub. Aber der eigentliche Sinn von
diesem Service ist, dass wir eine Test Anwendung haben, wo wir unsere Cloud Geschichten mitmachen
können. Also die eigentliche Anwendung ist ja, das ist alles. Das ist die Anwendung.
Das war's. Das ist alles. Kekweseservice. Wer braucht sie dafür nicht? Dass die Seite
rotiert. Wir haben natürlich die Bilder pregenerated. Guck hier. Haben wir 365 degree KekW. Aber
der eigentliche Sinn von dem Projekt ist ja, dass wir was zum Deployen haben für unsere
Cloud Ausflüge und Spurenzchen hier. Die Streams kommen ja auch immer ziemlich gut an. Übrigens
Ausrufezeichen Hetzner in den Chat. Wenn ihr auf der Suche nach einer günstigen Hausregel
Möglichkeit für virtuelle Linux Server seid, dann könnt ihr jetzt mal vorbeigucken bei
meinem Partner Hetzner Cloud und euch einen 20 Euro Startguthaben sichern. Hab ich gut
auswendig gelernt. Aber ernsthaft, ich verwende das selbst schon jahrelang. Ich hatte damit
nie Probleme. Ich bin damit eigentlich wirklich recht glücklich. Ich hoffe, sie haben demnächst
Kisten ohne IPv4 Adresse, dass es noch günstiger wird. Aber ansonsten, wenn ihr es ausprobieren
wollt, ihr könnt euch eine kleine Kiste kaufen für vier Euro ungefähr. Und die könnt ihr
eine Weile laufen lassen für 20 Euro. Wenn es euch nicht gefällt, dann lasst das sein.
Er gilt übrigens nur für neue Kunden. Ihr könnt das im Registrationsprozess einlösen,
den Code. Ich glaube, den Code kann man einlösen, nachdem man sich registriert hat. Es ist
ein Profil. Ich habe das noch nie selbst eingelöst. Ja, da kam es wirklich günstig. Also kann
es sich echt nicht beschweren. Es war noch vor kurzem noch günstiger, aber ich hoffe,
es wird wieder, wenn die sagen, IPv4 geht komplett ohne. Weil irgendwelche Backendserver,
denen brauche ich eigentlich gar keine Public IPv4 zu geben. Eigentlich total bescheuert.
Ich hoffe, die machen das. So. Okay, wie viel Zeit haben wir noch? 20 Minuten. Eine Sache
machen wir jetzt noch. Ich will gerade nochmal was fertig ausprobieren. Also wir generieren
jetzt hier ja eine Zufalls-ID. Wie weiß Info? Wir haben eine Zufalls-ID generiert. Okay.
So, also den ganzen Mist hier oben könnte ich eigentlich wegmachen. Hetzener paar Gutscheine
für Bestandskunden. Das ist eine gute Idee. Das schreibe ich mir mal auf. Vor allem, wenn
es das, wenn es das, das wäre natürlich sehr cool, wenn das funktioniert. Da muss ich
dich mal fragen, ja. Auf den Nightbot, also nur ich habe Admin Zugriff auf den Nightbot.
Also die Mods, ihr könnt, ihr könnt glaube ich Kommandos hinzufügen und löschen. Aber
ich glaube, admin-technisch könnt ihr nichts machen. Ja genau, das gibt es ja halt aktuell
nicht. Wenn du den Server anlegst, hat er immer eine IPv4 Adresse. Immer. Public IPv4,
die brauchst du eigentlich gar nicht. So, also eine sinnvolle Sache machen wir jetzt
noch. Warum fragst du? Max FPS, wie kommst du denn da drauf? Unmöglich, kann nicht sein.
Ich bin Wubblors, Mann. Ey Digga alter Lan, ich bin Wubblors. Paints-Champ. Bestandskunden-Kunfig,
ich kann es mal probieren. Ich kann es mal probieren. Ich kann ihm mal anschreiben, ob
wir nicht für Weihnachten irgendwas organisieren können. Also Gewinnspiel technisch. Ne, das
auf den Timer will ich nicht setzen. Dann habe ich zu viel mit Timer. Es reicht ja
schon das Ausrufezeichen Wubblors in den Chat. Leute, ich glaube, das war der längste Stream
seit langem. Okay, eine Sache, wie gesagt, eine Sache wollte ich jetzt mal machen. Also
wir haben den Kram jetzt hier generiert. Ich will jetzt einfach mal gucken, ob das im Prinzip
funktioniert, was ich hier, was ich hier gebastelt habe. Also State, wir brauchen ein State-Topic.
Und State-Topic, das ergibt jetzt schon überhaupt keinen Sinn. Alter, was mache ich denn hier?
So, State-Topic ist immer das gleiche. Immer Switch-State, nur mit dem Unterschied. Ach
so, Name muss ich noch übergeben für den Sensor. Ja, Name braucht das Ding auf jeden
Fall. Also Name, den brauchen wir bestimmt nochmal. Name, ich kann echt nicht mehr reden.
Ich mache jetzt unten Corona-Tests, Alter. Ich sage es euch. Ich habe noch einen. Alter,
ich habe echt, mir tut sogar ein bisschen der Hals weh. Ja, das ist nice. Ja, deswegen,
das ist auch die Sache, warum ich angefangen habe. Ich habe selbst so viele Stellenanzeigen
gesehen, wo ich mir gedacht habe, das kann doch nicht euer Ernst sein. Das kann ja noch
nicht ernst sein. Da habe ich mir dann irgendwann überlegt, hey, warum machst du da nicht einfach
Videos zu? Das kommt ja auch immer gut an. Echt, hattest du Corona? Ich bin aber geimpft.
Doppelt. Oh, das ist schon ein paar Wochen näher. Ich kann gar kein Corona haben. Aber
ich habe ja auch keinerlei Probleme mit sonst irgendwas. Ich habe keinen Fieber. Ich habe
keine Atemprobleme oder irgendwas. Ich habe einfach nur der Hals weh. Kochsalzlösung
Impfung. Was denkst du über Battlefield 242? Auf Reddit alle Panik. Ach Quatsch. Reddit
kann es nichts geben. Also ich fand das, was ich gesehen habe, gut. Ich hoffe es gibt
demnächst ein Anspiel Event, wo ich mitmachen darf. Hoffe ich. Offiziell weiß ich es ja
nicht. Da kann ich mir selbst ein Bild davon machen. Sollte das so sein? Und dann werde
ich mal gucken. Ich glaube, warum soll das auf einmal sacken? Das ist Reddit. Reddit
kann es nichts geben. Also erstens die Beta ist uralt gewesen. Bestimmt 2-3 Monate. Wenn
nicht im Kern vielleicht sogar noch ein Ticken älter. Die sind sicherlich weiter. Und für
was jetzt wirklich der Grund für die Verschiebung ist, das können wir gar nicht so genau sagen.
Corona wird es nicht sein. Corona ist vielleicht mit dafür verantwortlich, aber das werden
die nicht jetzt erst gemerkt haben. Also Corona wird es nicht sein, auch wenn die das reingeschrieben
haben. Das ist halt einfach nur eine gute Ausrede zurzeit. Es wird wahrscheinlich entweder,
haben sie festgestellt, dass es doch mehr Bugs gibt, die Gameplay technisch nicht so
gut ankommen, die sie fixen wollen. Oder vielleicht sind auch ein paar wichtige Leute
krank geworden. Man kann das echt schlecht beurteilen. Oh, ein Byte Strike. Du kommst
gerade richtig. Ich wollte jetzt aufgehen. Wir machen Leute, hat es euch gefallen? Ich
glaube schon. Es waren durchschnittlich, glaube ich, 230, 250 Leute da. Richtig nice.
Es ist schön, wenn es euch gefallen hat. Wir machen auch demnächst weiter. Ich kann
noch nicht mal richtig reden. Ich muss erst mal Corona test bleiben. Corona. Was macht
eigentlich der Frasier? Der war mal wieder on gewesen in letzter Zeit. Der Fred. Irgendwelche
Web-Mobile-Games, Alter. Der Frasier wieder. Anime-Wifu-Games, ja. Rated ihn doch gerade mal. Hab ich das letzte Mal schon gemacht.
Da hat er sich, glaube ich, sogar noch drüber beschwert. Jetzt kommen die ganzen Leute wieder
zu. Ich raid ihn heute nicht. Ich glaube auch nicht, dass das was ist, was euch großartig
interessiert. Raid Coder2k. Wer ist denn Coder2k? Kenn ich nicht. Jetzt kommt irgendein Boop-Camp-Streamer
oder so. Coder2k. Ist das C++? Okay, es ist was mit Gaming. Da lasse ich es mir doch irgendwie
gefallen. Ja, da lasse ich es mir schon gefallen. Wir gucken mal, was gibt es denn so? Was gibt
es hier denn so? Oh, das ist der XQC des Terminals. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass der streamt. Ich
wusste gar nicht, dass der streamt, Alter. Was? RPE Cloud? Kanäle auf Deutsch. Refactoring.
Wir kauen ein Retro-Game. Was gibt es denn da so? Nicht.
Ich wusste gar keinen. Sehr gut. Kann das sein, dass die Kategorie nicht so beliebt
ist? Na gut, das ist jetzt auch auf Deutsch, auf Deutsch only. Wie sieht es denn international
so aus? Off-Down-Game-Development. Was haben wir denn da? Programming-Grills? Java-Skript.
Den kenne ich. Der macht auf YouTube gute Tutorials. Java-Skript-CSS-Zeug. Da lernt
man CSS. Ach, keine Ahnung. Leute, ich gehe jetzt auf. Ich gehe jetzt was essen, was trinken,
dass der Hals morgen auch noch weh tut. Dann gucken wir mal, was da rauskommt. Was? Plaximo?
Ergibt sich Mühe? Okay. Wenn der Chat das sagt, muss man mal kurz gucken. Wer ist das?
Twitch? Sagt mir gar nichts. Streckenelemente automatisch generieren. Ergibt sich, ich habe
ihn schon nie gehört. Guckst du den öfters? Baldisos? Okay, es ist zumindest schonmal
eine ordentliche Programmiersprache. Da bin ich ganz begeistert. Komm, wir wollen mal
nicht so sein. Auf geht's. Raid. Bam. Ich bin dann aber nicht im Chat. Ich gehe jetzt
gleich runter, was trinken tut der Hals weh. Community habe ich auch überhaupt keinen Plan.
Es ist auch echt sowas, wo es mich überhaupt nicht dazu hinzieht. Vielleicht will ich mir
meinen Spaß an Games nicht verderben, wenn ich weiß, wie es funktioniert. Kein Schimmer.
Wir sehen uns. Bis dann. Macht's gut. See you.